David Boder: [In English] We are starting again. Munich, Septem—...Germany, September the 23rd in Camp Feldafing...Camp Feldafing, near Munich, a camp for about four thousand and several hundred DPs. The camp is located on a large compound of about fifteen to twenty acres, covered with armory-like buildings, which was a camp of the Hitler Youth. Apparently very similar to those school sites built in New Jersey, which I understand the Klan [?] took over for some time. The interviewee is Mrs. Helena Tichauer, sometimes, as she says, known in Auschwitz and here as Zippi. She is married to Mr. Mack...to Mr. Tichauer who was our interviewee on Spool 146, 147 [these numbers are incorrect]. Mr. Tichauer was called in our spools Irving.
David Boder: [In German] Also Frau Tichauer, wollen Sie mir sagen, hm, wie alt sind Sie und Ihren vollen Namen und wie alt sind Sie, wenn man das wissen darf.
Helen Tichauer: Tichauer Helene, geborene Spitzer.
David Boder: Spitzer?
Helen Tichauer: Spitzer, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Geboren im November, am zehnten (10.) November 1918.
David Boder: Wo?
Helen Tichauer: In Bratislava in der Tschechoslowakei.
David Boder: Also Sie sind Tschechoslowakin?
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: Ich sehe, Sie haben hier ein Tattoo-Nummer. Von wo ist das
Helen Tichauer: Meine Nummer zweitausend zwei hundert sechs und achtzig (2286) gehört zu den ersten Nummern die Frauen im Jahre zwei und vierzig (42)—im März 42 nach Auschwitz kamen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun wollen Sie mir erzählen, wieso...von dem Tag an, wo die Aktion war, die Sie nach Auschwitz gebracht hat und was hat weiter passiert.
Helen Tichauer: Also die Aktion, wie sie eigentlich nach Auschwitz kamen, ist in diesem Falle auch interessant.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Der slowakische Staat bekam von Hitler seine Selbstständigkeit. Zum Preis gab der damalige Ministerpräsident Vojtech Tuka sechzig tausend (60000) Juden...und hat sie den Deutschen zur Verfügung übergeben. Und das ist dem Erich Kaha, da war der [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wie hat man diese Juden genommen?
Helen Tichauer: Diese Juden wurden aufgefordert, zuerst wurden Frauen aufgefordert und Jugendliche bis zu fünf und vierzig Jahre sich freiwillig an einer Stelle in Bratislava– das war die Patronka—zu melden. Gesagt wurde ihnen nicht viel, aber zum größten Teil, dass sie auf landwirtschaftliche Arbeit in die Nord Slowakei gehen. Die Transporte kamen an, das heißt, die Leute haben sich in dem Lager gesammelt und am...am...der erste Transport von tausend Mädchen ging am sechs und zwanzigsten (26.) März aus der Stadt Botraczek...
David Boder: Zwei und vierzig (42).
Helen Tichauer: Zwei und vierzig (42)—im Jahre. Einen Tag später ging der zweite (2.) Transport—wieder von tausend Frauen. Wir fuhren die ganze Nacht.
David Boder: In welchem Transport waren Sie? Im zweiten (2.) Transport?
Helen Tichauer: Im zweiten (2.) Transport.
David Boder: Alright, erzählen Sie also was hat passiert. Sie haben sich versammelt. Was haben Sie mitgehabt?
Helen Tichauer: Nichts richtig. Also wir haben uns versammelt. Sofort an dem selben Tag mussten wir unsere Ausweispapiere abgeben und mussten uns verpflichten, die Dinge, die uns...das heißt, fünfzig (50) Kilo durften wir uns mit nehmen und wir mussten uns verpflichten, die Dinge, die wir zurück gelassen haben, dem Staat zur Verfügung zu stellen.
David Boder: Hm.
Helen Tichauer: Wir wurden zu diesem Form...Formular so quasi gezwungen.
David Boder: Nun und wie haben Sie dies dem Staat so quasi zur Verfügung gestellt?
Helen Tichauer: Überhaupt nicht, wir wissen auch gar nicht, was damit geschehen ist, weil wir wurden eine Woche später von der Sammelstelle, wo wir von der ganzen Welt abgeschnitten waren, abtransportiert mit unseren fünfzig (50) Kilos.
David Boder: Also, nun einen Moment. Wo waren Ihr Vater , Ihre Mutter und...?
Helen Tichauer: Meine Eltern waren zu Haue gewesen. Überhaupt alle Eltern waren noch zu Hause. Die ersten Transporte bestanden aus ledigen Mädchen, die aufgefordert wurden nichts zu tun, zu kommen; falls sie nicht kommen würden, hätte man...würde man Massregeln treffen und die Eltern dafür nehmen. Aus dem einfachen Grunde hat es kein Mädchen gewagt nicht zu kommen, denn jedem waren die Eltern [unverständlich], weil man die schlechtesten Vorahnungen dabei hat; da war man bereit sich zu opfern.
David Boder: Nun?
Helen Tichauer: Nun, wir wurden also nach einer Woche, genau nach...
David Boder: Nun bitte nicht so schnell, wer hat sie bewacht?
Helen Tichauer: Bewacht haben uns damals die Grinka Garnison. Das waren Parallele zu der damaligen SS, die zur damaligen Zeit in der Slowakei SS genannt wurde, entsprechend der deutschen SS.
David Boder: Also es war nicht die deutsche SS.
Helen Tichauer: Nein, die Deutschen selbst haben erst am letzten Tag dieses Sammellager übernommen, die Leute aufgestellt und mit dem Transport begleitet.
David Boder: Ah so, nun bitte weiter.
Helen Tichauer: Die Reise dauerte eine Nacht und einen Tag.
David Boder: Also in was für Wagons wurden sie hinein gesetzt?
Helen Tichauer: Es waren normale Viehwagons.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen, dass es nicht normale Viehwagons gibt?
Helen Tichauer: Doch.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel.
Helen Tichauer: Zum Beispiel, Viehwagons, die eventuell [unverständlich], die ohne Dach sind.
David Boder: Aha, offene Wagons!
Helen Tichauer: Diese waren geschlossen. Der war verschlossen und die Türe natürlich auch mit einem entsprechenden Schloss versehen, so dass wir nicht die Möglichkeit hatten, das Tageslicht zu bekommen und auch keine Ahnung hatten in welcher Richtung wir eigentlich fahren.
David Boder: Hatten Sie eine Toilette im Wagon?
Helen Tichauer: Eine Toilette nicht, nein, aber es waren Eimer, die zu diesem Zweck gedient haben.
David Boder: Wie viele Leute in einem Wagon?
Helen Tichauer: In einen Wagon wurden ungefähr sechzig (60) bis achtzig (80) Leute einwagoniert.
David Boder: In Ihrem Fall bloß Frauen?
Helen Tichauer: In unserem Fall bloß Frauen...,
David Boder: Oder jünger?
Helen Tichauer: . . . nur Mädchen bis zu 45 Jahren.
David Boder: Also keine verheirateten Frauen?
Helen Tichauer: Keine verheirateten Ehepaare, denn die kamen erst zwei (2) Monate später.
David Boder: Aber waren verheiratete Frauen dabei?
Helen Tichauer: Verheiratet Frauen nicht.
David Boder: Nun weiter. Auch keine kleinen Kinder?
Helen Tichauer: Kleine Kinder auch nicht. An der Grenze—ungefähr am nächsten Tag in der Früh bemerkten wir, dass wir uns irgendwo in einer fremden Gegend befinden. Nach langem Hin- und Her-Grübeln kamen wir darauf, dass wir in die Richtung Ober Schlesien gefahren sind. Wir kamen an der Bahnstation Cieszyn an und wussten genau, dass wir in die Richtung Polen fahren.
David Boder: Hat Ihnen jemand gesagt, wohin sie fahren?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, darüber bekamen wir keine Auskunft. Ganz im Gegenteil.
David Boder: Ja, man hat Ihnen aber am Anfang gesagt, dass Sie in die Slowakei fahren.
Helen Tichauer: Am Anfang hat man gesagt, es geht nach der Nord Slowakei zur Feldarbeit. Als wir sahen, dass wir in Polen angekommen, waren wir der Meinung, dass wir vielleicht in Polen auf dem Feld arbeiten gehen. Denn es waren ja auch schon in Polen Gerüchte verbreitet, dass man teilweise in Polen, teilweise nach der Ukraine Feldarbeiter braucht. Wir haben uns dabei nicht viel gedacht, denn es war uns versprochen, dass wir nach zwei Monaten nach Hause gehen. Und wir wären gerne bereit gewesen zwei Monate abzuarbeiten, nur um unsere Eltern auf diese Art zu schützen.
David Boder: Haben Sie überhaupt schon gewusst, was in den Lagern passiert? Hat man das in Ungarn...in der Slowakei gewusst?
Helen Tichauer: Eigentlich nicht, denn für Frauen war das ja ziemlich unbekannt. Wir wussten von deutschen Konzentrationslagern aus dem einfachen Grunde, weil doch ein Grossteil dieser Immigranten—der deutschen Immigranten hauptsächlich—in der Slowakei—der Tschechoslowakei zur damaligen Zeit toleriert waren und...
David Boder: Waren das Leute, die weg gelaufen sind?
Helen Tichauer: . . . die teilweise auch entlassen wurden, teilweise weg gelaufen sind. Zum Grossteil wussten ja Juden, was ein deutsches Konzentrationslager ist. Aber nie im Leben hätten wir uns geträumt, dass man uns ganz harmlos, nur darum in ein Konzentrationslager stecken würde, weil wir eben Juden sind. Nun am nächsten Tag, es war ein Samstag nachmittag gegen fünf (5) Uhr, blieb der Zug vor der Station Oswiecim—Auschwitz stehen. Um uns irgendwie...
David Boder: Wo ist das ungefähr? Bei welcher großen Stadt ist das?
Helen Tichauer: Ja, das ist...Auschwitz, das ist eine große Stadt. Es liegt aber zwischen Katowice und Krakau.
David Boder: Ja. Bitte sprechen Sie in diese Richtung.
Helen Tichauer: Hier konnte wir uns nicht orientieren, denn Auschwitz war uns unbekannt. Es war im Großen und Ganzen für uns nichts als ein Konzentrationslager bekannt. Wir kamen, wie ich schon erwähnt, nachmittags gegen 5 Uhr an. Der Zug hält, wir wurden in einem ziemlich komischen Ton erwartet. Wir haben nur ein Gebrüll gehört, denn die Wagons waren versperrt. Immer rascher, rascher, los und so weiter. Wenn unser Wagon dran kam, wurden wir herunter gejagt. Vor uns standen uniformierte Menschen, die wir ja früher nicht kannten, denn in der Slowakei hatten wir keine Möglichkeit richtige Totenköpfe zu sehen.
David Boder: Also die Meisten hatten Totenköpfe auf der Uniform?
Helen Tichauer: Hatten Totenköpfe...
David Boder: Bitte beschreiben Sie die Uniform.
Helen Tichauer: Die Uniform war eine normale SS Uniform, dunkel grün, halb hohe Stiefeln, also eine Art deutsche Stiefeln, Wehrmachtsstiefeln. Die Klappen an den...
David Boder: An den...an den Röcken.
Helen Tichauer: . . . and den Jacken waren mit SS bezeichnet und auf der Mütze, auf der Schirmmütze, die die meisten getragen haben, war ein Totenkopf zu sehen.
David Boder: Mit zwei Beinen?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, ein Kopf, nur ein Totenkopf. Das war das Abzeichen...glaube ich...ein Totenkopf. Das war dieses [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Das war doch bekannt. Wir wurden heraus gejagt...
David Boder: Was heißt heraus gejagt?
Helen Tichauer: Mit einem „raus, raus“ in einem Ton, so dass wir verstanden haben, dass wir raus zu gehen haben. Wir würden schnell noch in Fünfer Reihen aufgestellt und nach einer Richtung—zu der Tür
David Boder: Haben Sie Ihre Sachen genommen?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, unsere Sachen wurde uns nicht gegeben. Die Sachen haben wir auch nie mehr zu sehen bekommen.
David Boder: Sie haben Sie nicht mehr gesehen?
Helen Tichauer: Niemals mehr zu sehen bekommen.
David Boder: Sie sind in dem Wagon geblieben?
Helen Tichauer: Sie blieben im Wagon. Und am Weg—da haben wir etwas, was ich eigentlich heute kaum mehr beschreiben kann, gesehen. Es war ein ganz großes [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Halb angefertigte Stein Blöcke umgeben von Stacheldraht. Auf den Dächern und in den Fenstern standen gestreifte, lebende Korpse. Ich kann mich nicht anders ausdrücken. Menschen ohne Gesichter, der Gesichtsausdruck wie angemauert. Neben ihnen sind gestanden damals...also heute weiß ich, sie waren Posten, sozusagen Posten, die diese Häftlinge bewachten und, und...es waren Männer. Als sie uns sahen, wurden sie...wie sie ihre Aufmerksamkeit auf uns lenkten, wurden sie angebrüllt, so dass sie es nicht mehr wagten ihren Kopf umzudrehen und ihre Arbeit weiter verrichteten. Es wurde damals, nachdem ich es heute eher begreife, das Lager Auschwitz für uns, für die Frauen, fertig gestellt sozusagen, denn die meisten waren oben auf den Dächern.
David Boder: Waren Sie [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband].
Helen Tichauer: Das stimmt. Es war eigentlich ein Männer Lager schon seit neunzehn hundert vierzig (1940) oder neun und dreißig (39) schon fertig, aber für die Frauen, die man jetzt erwartet hat, wurden zehn (10) Blocks zur Verfügung gestellt. Es waren Steinblocks einen Stock hoch mit Kellerräumen und Bodenräumen. Wir waren tausend (1000) Mädchen. Wir betraten das Lager, das heißt vor dem Lager war das Tor mit der Anschrift, „Arbeit macht frei“.
David Boder: Das selbe wie in Dachau.
Helen Tichauer: Ja. Natürlich waren wir der Meinung, dass wir in ein Arbeitslager...in ein Arbeitslager gekommen sind. Aber nicht weit von dem Tor auf der linken Seite, wenn man sich nach links gewendet hätte, konnte man in deutscher Sprache in gedruckter Blockschrift die Anschrift „Konzentrationslager Auschwitz“ sehen, das in uns, sozusagen in uns, schon Unruhe erweckte. Die tausend (1000) Mädchen, die ins Lager kamen, sahen vor sich, das heißt bevor dem letzten Block, das war Block zehn (10), Gestalten. Wir wussten im ersten Augenblick nicht, was das eigentlich ist, ob das Mädchen, ob das Frauen oder ob es überhaupt Menschen sind. Sie standen da vereinzelt in russischen Uniformen, das Haar kahl geschoren, Holzpantoffel an den Beinen und standen und gafften uns an. Dann plötzlich ertönten einige Rufe. Bekannte Mädchen haben Freundinnen oder Schwestern oder dergleichen erkannt und nach langem...
David Boder: Sie haben gesagt, sie waren dort?
Helen Tichauer: Sie sind einen Tag früher gekommen.
David Boder: Sie haben kahle Köpfe gehabt.
Helen Tichauer: Sie waren schon...sozusagen Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Nun und
David Boder: Sie hatten ihre Haare geschoren?
Helen Tichauer: Sie hatten ihre Haare schon geschoren. Viel sprechen konnte man nicht, denn wir waren umgeben von SS, aber wir haben in dem Moment begriffen, dass es unsere nächsten Frauen aus der Slowakei sind und in welchem Zustand sie sich befinden. Das hat uns aber genügt, es dauerte nicht lange. Das heißt, wir kommen an, und was wir noch hatten an Mäntel, Kleider, Schuhe und Strümpfe und dergleichen wurde uns abgenommen und so hundert (100) in einer Gruppe kamen wir nach einem Block, das man die Sauna nannte. .
David Boder: Was?
Helen Tichauer: Das war ein Bad, Sauna.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Es war ein Bad, wo man die Frauen gebadet hat, wo sie...das ist, wo man uns das Haar geschoren hat. Man hat uns russische Uniformen überreicht.
David Boder: Männer Uniformen?
Helen Tichauer: Russische Männer Uniformen, alte. Und nach ein paar Stunden waren wir unseren ersten Ankömmlingen, die vor uns angekommen sind, gleich geartet...
David Boder: Nun warten Sie bitte, was hat man getan? Man hat Ihnen alles weggenommen, was Sie mit sich hatten?
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: Man hat Sie dann in ein Bad hinein getrieben, ja?
David Boder: Und dann hat man Ihnen die Harre abgeschnitten.
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: Wer?
Helen Tichauer: Wer? Ein Moment. Bevor die ersten jüdischen Transporte aus der Slowakei kamen, kamen vorher tausend Reichsdeutsche Häftlinge aus Ravensbrück.
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Helen Tichauer: Frauen, weil in den Frauenlagern gab es nur Frauen. Wir hatten mit Männern überhaupt keinen Kontakt. Das war nicht erlaubt. Diese Frauen-Häftlinge, die schon drei (3) und vier (4) und fünf (5) Jahre eingesperrt waren, wurden strafweise aus dem Konzentrationslager...von dem Konzentrationslager Ravensbrück nach Auschwitz transportiert. Diese Frauen haben dann uns eben eingekleidet, gebadet, das Haar geschoren und uns übergeben der SS. Die Häftlinge, die Reichsdeutschen Häftlinge...
David Boder: Sie wurden geschoren und gebadet...
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und sind da SS Männer reingekommen?
Helen Tichauer: Es kamen zur damaligen Zeit der Lager-Führer, vom damaligen Auschwitz der Lager-Führer, der Obersturmband Führer Ohrmeier und viele andere, deren Namen mir nicht bekannt sind, hierher um uns wie Vieh zu beobachten. Es ist wie auf einer Viehschau gewesen. Sie haben uns hin und her gedreht...
David Boder: Sie nackt waren?
Helen Tichauer: Nackt. Und ausserdem war noch der SS Arzt Dr. Bodermann, damals der Auschwitz Lagerarzt, der uns eben angesehen hat und ich weiß nicht...gemustert hat uns und dann den normales Prozess, wie Baden und Haare scheren und abschneiden, hat durch genommen.
David Boder: Und die Männer waren dabei?
Helen Tichauer: Die SS Männer, ja. Die erste Nacht...
David Boder: Die Haare hat man Ihnen nur vom Kopf geschnitten?
Helen Tichauer: Das Haar wurden uns von allen Stellen, wo es überhaupt Haare am Körper gibt—auch unsere Augenbrauen und so weiter, abgeschoren.
David Boder: Mit Scheren oder mit...?
Helen Tichauer: Teilweise mit elektrischen Maschinen, so wie Schneidemaschinen und wenn diese dann versagt haben, hat man eben Scheren angewendet, die zumeist halb stumpf waren. Einige Wochen später, wurde uns nachdem man Tausende von Häftlingen täglich aus der Slowakei, aus Polen in diesen Monaten gebracht hat, aus Polen kamen die ersten Häftlinge aus dem Gefängnis nach Auschwitz, hat man dann irgendwie, um ein bisschen Übersicht zu haben, haben sie begonnen sich mit der Tätowierung zu befassen. Die ersten Methoden waren...sie haben eigentlich versagt. Die ersten Methoden waren entsprechend eines Stempels. Sie haben Nadeln in Form von Nummern neben einander gereiht und ganz einfach auf den Arm gedrückt und mit Tusche beschmiert. Nach einigen Tagen war die Tätowierung weg. Nun kam die normale Tätowierung mit der Doppelnadel, die dann jedem Häftling von eins bis fortlaufend auf dem linken Arm angebracht wurde.
David Boder: Wie wurde das gemacht, haben sie [unverständlich] aufgekratzt?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, es...für die Armtätowierung, das ist eine Doppelnadel. Eine Nadel ist länger, die Andere kürzer. Und die wurde in Tusche eingetaucht und dann durch [unverständlich] leichte Tätowierung.
David Boder: Tut das sehr weh?
Helen Tichauer: Weh? Wir haben den Schmerz nicht mehr gefühlt, an und für sich die Kleider, das Entfernen der Haare von unseren Köpfen and all das war sehr emotionell, die Haare, das ist auch sehr tragisch für eine Frau als für einen Mann, das ist anders bei uns [unverständlich; Tonband ist so leise, dass man es nicht verstehen kann] die ganzen Transformation, die wir zu dieser Zeit durch gemacht haben, hat mehr weh getan, so dass wir nichts mehr gefühlt haben. Wir hatten gar nichts mehr gefühlt, wir waren zu...zu Stein geworden. Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das sagen kann.
David Boder: Ja. Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Aber es hat uns auch nichts mehr bewegt, nichts was sie uns auch angetan haben. Wenn man unsere Nagel, unsere Zehennägel geschnitten hat oder was auch immer, nichts hat uns mehr etwas aus gemacht. Weil wir wussten, dass wir jetzt völlig von der Zivilisation, von der Menschheit abgeschnitten sind und dass wir uns jetzt auf einem Hinweis befinden, wo die Menschen doch noch leben.
David Boder: Nun.
Helen Tichauer: Nun. Die erste Nacht wurden wir in diesem Steinblock untergebracht. Zusammengepfercht vor allem,. Weil das Lager war ja eigentlich noch nicht fertig aufgebaut. Es waren alte Strohsäcke noch vom Männerlager, verfaulte, die wurden auf den Boden aufgelegt...
David Boder: Nach dem ganzen Waschen?
Helen Tichauer: Nach der ganzen Prozedur,...teilweise waren da nicht einmal genug Strohsäcke. Und man hat sich eben dort hingelegt, wo Platz war. Mit einem Stück Brot abgefertigt, haben wir die Nacht verbracht. Am nächsten Tag begann für uns etwas ganz Neues.
David Boder: Wer hat sie tätowiert? Männer oder Frauen?
Helen Tichauer: Es waren...diese Tätowierung wurde eigentlich durchgeführt zwei (2) Monate später.
David Boder: Oh ja.
Helen Tichauer: Die gründliche Tätowierung. Die Erste wurde auch von Häftlingen gemacht, von Häftlingen damals...
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Helen Tichauer: Männer, immer wieder Männer. Nun...
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Ja [unverständlich; Tonband ist fast unhörbar]. Am nächsten Tag, es war noch dunkel—wurden wir durch ein Gepfeife, durch ein Geschrei aufgeweckt. Man hörte das Wort Appell. Appell war für uns etwas ganz Unbekanntes. Wir dachten momentan Appell ist für Soldaten, Appell ist irgendwo...für Soldaten. Vielleicht wollen sie uns auch zu Soldaten machen. Wir standen auf und wurden raus gejagt und...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie? Wer...?
Helen Tichauer: Rausgejagt durch SS Frauen auf den Hof. Wir wussten nicht genau, was wir tun sollen. Dann kam...
David Boder: Haben sie Sie geschlagen?
Helen Tichauer: In den ersten Stunden konnte ich davon...konnte ich davon gar nicht sprechen. Es war ja noch...wir haben ja noch...wir waren ja noch...tatsächlich waren wir [unverständlich] ja?
David Boder: Was heißt, sie wollten nicht davon sprechen?
Helen Tichauer: Ich kann nicht...ich kann darüber nicht reden. Wir waren ohne Bewusstsein, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich einen Schlag gefühlt habe oder nicht. Eines weiß ich, wir wurden aufgestellt, so aufgestellt, dass man uns nach langem Hin und Her zählen wollte. Zu einer Zählung kam es natürlich nicht, weil...
David Boder: Warum natürlich nicht?
Helen Tichauer: Warum nicht? Denn es war ein furchtbares Chaos. Diese SS Frauen, die damals das Lager zu führen hatten, es war damals die Oberaufsichts..., die Rapportführerin Margot Drexel, die in erster Zeit ja gar nicht wusste, was sie tun sollte. Sie hatte noch keine Erfahrung. Sie hat die Menschen aufstellen lassen und wie man versucht hat uns durch zu zählen, hat die Zahl ja immer noch nicht gestimmt. Wenn die Häftlinge jetzt zum Teil nicht wussten...in der einen...in der einen Gruppe stand die Schwester, in der anderen stand vielleicht die Kusine. Man lief von einer Gruppe zur anderen. Auf der einen Gruppe war...bei der einen Gruppe war die Anzahl grösser, bei der anderen kleiner. Nun waren es in den ersten Tag ganz unmöglich wirklich einen Appell zusammen zu kriegen.
David Boder: Wie haben sie gezählt, haben sie Nummern gegeben?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, man hat die Leute zu fünft aufgestellt hinter einander und hat dann...
David Boder: Wie wurden die Leute gezählt?
Helen Tichauer: Sie wurden bei Reihen gezählt.
David Boder: Nicht bei Personen?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, nein, nein, nein, das kam in den ersten Tage doch nicht in Frage. Und mit der Zeit haben die Häftlinge auch gelernt sich aufzustellen, hat der Rapportführer auch gelernt richtig zusammen zu zählen und wenn der Appell stimmt, konnte man abtreten.
David Boder: Wie lange hat solch ein Appell gedauert?
Helen Tichauer: Ein Appell, wenn er geschickt gemacht war,...
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: . . . konnte er in 10 Minuten fertig sein.
David Boder: Aber wie lange hat es [unverständlich] gedauert?
Helen Tichauer: In den ersten Tagen habe Appelle oft auch vier (4) Stunden gedauert.
David Boder: In dem ersten Jahr oder in den ersten Tagen?
Helen Tichauer: In den ersten Tagen. Ich sollte sagen, was immer wieder abhängig war...Es wurde ein Häftling dort erwählt, der der Rapportfuehrerin, der SS Frau, assistiert. Also das ist, der ihr hilft. Dieser Häftling war in dem ersten Jahr...also im ersten Jahr...ich werde sagen ein Analphabet; also sie konnte kaum rechnen. Von praktischer Arbeit war keine Rede und sie war auch gar nicht interessiert daran, dass sie jetzt mit der Zählung rasch abgefertigt werden. Zum ersten Mal, im Jahre neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943) wurde eine jüdische Rapportführerin ernannt. Aufmerksam wurde man auf sie dadurch, dass sie in der ersten Zeit gleich als Blockälteste ernannt wurde und sich gut bewährte. Sie war von Beruf ein Stenograph, konnte rechnen, konnte schreiben und lesen und war daran interessiert ihren Mitmenschen zu helfen. [unverständlich] und dank ihrer leben heute viele, viel Häftlinge aus unserem Land und auch aus anderen Ländern. Sie hat es zu Stande gebracht, dass Appell oft in zehn (10) Minuten geklappt haben und dass die Häftlinge im Regen oder in der größten Kälte nach einigen Minuten abtreten konnten. Nach zwei (2) oder drei (3) Monaten—es war im August—waren schon täglich tausend (1000) Mädchen aus der Slowakei gekommen, teilweise arische Häftlinge, politische Häftlinge aus Polen, von...
David Boder: Was nennt man einen politischen Häftling?
Helen Tichauer: Ein politischer Häftling war im deutschen Sinne die gewesen, die der deutschen Macht irgendwie etwas zu Schulden hat kommen lassen. Sie haben selbst Frauen, Reichsdeutsche Frauen, die bloß einen polnischen Freund hatten als Polnische behandelt und zum politischen Häftling ernannt. Also im August wurde unsere Nummer schon die Zahl sieben tausend (7000) erreicht haben und das Fleckfieber und Malaria ihre ersten Opfer—ja das Fleckfieber, wie ihre ersten Opfer gefallen sind, haben die Deutschen entschlossen, eigentlich die SS Lagerführung beschlossen, das Frauenlager Auschwitz vier (4) Kilometer weiter nach Birkenau übersiedeln zu lassen. Damals blieben über zwei tausend (2000) Häftlinge—Frauenhäftlinge, die irgendwie nicht gesund waren, in Auschwitz; der Rest wurde nach Birkenau übersiedelt.
David Boder: Wo waren die Krematorien? Die Krematorien waren in Birkenau?
Helen Tichauer: Moment, Moment.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Krematorium eins (1) war ein modernes Krematorium in Auschwitz, welches nur dazu diente Leichen zu verbrennen. Das kleine, weiße Haus, welches sich in Birkenau im Wald befand, war nichts anderes wie ein unschuldiges, kleines Häuschen. Ich selbst hatte im Jahre drei und vierzig (43), im Winter zwischen drei und vierzig (’43) und vier und vierzig (’44) die Möglichkeit dieses kleine Häuschen zu betreten. Denn dieses kleine Häuschen hat alle unsere Auschwitzer...unsere slowakischen Brüder und Schwestern auf dem Gewissen. Dieses weiße Häuschen hatte ein paar Fenster, eine große Eisentür und ein Schild: „Zum Bad“. Leute wurden damals in dieses Bad gejagt—laut Erzählungen von Leuten, die damals von Häftlingen, von Männern, die ich oben begegnete...es waren Männer vom Sonderkommando. Das Sonderkommand war dasjenige Kommando, welches aus Häftlingen bestanden ist. Häftlinge wurden gezwungen, die Leute in die Gaskammer zu jagen, sie im Totenzustand ins Krematorium zu befördern und sie zu verbrennen. Diese Leute hatten einige Monate Urlaub, wie Berlin diktierte, die Vergasungen einzustellen. Diese Leute haben damals im Winter...
David Boder: Was heißt sie mussten weg? Sie waren im Lager?
Helen Tichauer: Sie waren in einem Lager wurden aber auf ein Holzkommando geschickt. Sie mussten Holz fällen—eben in der Umgebung dieses Häuschens. Und da hatte ich die Möglichkeit irgendwie eine von den Sonderkommandos zu fragen, wie die Leute hier vergast wurden. Und er zeigte mir die Eisentür und das Fenster mit Gittern. Die Leute wurden herein gejagt—es war ein Raum. Die Türe, die Eisentür fiel zu. Durch die Eisengitter des Fensters wurde Gas rein gestreut und das Fenster automatisch verschlossen. Nach einigen Momenten, einigen Sekunden, einigen Minuten...je nachdem...bis die Leute eben tot waren, hat man sie auf „Loren“ befördert und in der Nähe waren Gruben, wo die Leute dann verbrannt wurden.
David Boder: Sie wurden nicht in dem Krematorium verbrannt, sie wurden in Gruben verbrannt?
Helen Tichauer: In Gruben verbrannt, damals noch. Ich will noch darauf zurück kommen, dass im August zwei und vierzig (42) als das Frauenlager nach Birkenau übersiedelte und die zwei tausend (2000) kranken Häftlinge in Auschwitz blieben, auch in dem kleinen Häuschen vergast wurden.
David Boder: Wer, die zwei tausend (2000)?
Helen Tichauer: Die zwei tausend (2000) Mädchen.
David Boder: Aber das kleine Häuschen war doch in Birkenau?
Helen Tichauer: Richtig. Sie wurden auf Lastautos geladen und herüber befördert.
David Boder: Oh.
Helen Tichauer: In Birkenau angekommen hörte man immer wieder von Transporten nach Lublin. Wir haben den Transport nicht geglaubt.
David Boder: Ein Moment. Haben Sie in Bir...in Auschwitz gearbeitet?
Helen Tichauer: Ich habe in Birkenau gearbeitet. Ich habe auch in den ersten Wochen in Auschwitz gearbeitet.
David Boder: Aha. Was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Helen Tichauer: Die ersten Wochen...war ich...auf dem Abrufkommando in Birkenau.
David Boder: Was heißt das Abrufkommando?
Helen Tichauer: Da waren noch ein paar zerschossene Häuser in Birkenau, die man demolieren musste. Die Arbeit...
David Boder: Haben Sie gelebt in Auschwitz?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, wir lebten...lebten in Auschwitz und gingen nach Birkenau demolieren.
David Boder: Zu Fuß?
Helen Tichauer: Zu Fuß, barfuss.
David Boder: Wie viele Kilometer?
Helen Tichauer: Es waren vier (4) Kilometer.
David Boder: Also...
Helen Tichauer: Später dann...wurde man auf mich aufmerksam. Nachdem die russischen Uniformen, die man uns eigentlich gab, nicht mehr ausreichend waren, beschloss man uns Zivilkleider zu geben. Zivilkleider waren ja genügend vorhanden, denn man hat den ganzen Frauen ihr Gepäck abgenommen und die schlechtesten Kleider eben ausgesucht und den Häftlingen zur Verfügung gestellt. Um uns aber von Zivilisten eventuell zu unterscheiden,...was heißt Zivilisten—mit Zivilisten kamen wir ja gar nicht in Berührung, aber falls die eine oder andere Möglichkeit bestand zu flüchten und um uns unterscheiden zu können, wurde damals vom Herrn Obersturmbandführer Ohrmeier angeordnet, mit roter Farbe, mit roter Ölfarbe hinten am Rücken von oben bis unten eine senkrechte, schwarze Linie zu ziehen. Ein roter Streifen. Nachdem man Maler vom Männerlager nicht ins Frauenlager schicken wollte, war man au der Suche nach einer Frau, die irgendwie mit Farben bekannt ist. Es gab nämlich Trockenfarbe und das entsprechende Öl und sie wollten, dass sich die Frauen selbst bedienen. Ich war damals die Einzige, die sich da zurück meldete. Ich wusste zwar nicht für welchen Zweck. Man suchte eine Malerin. Und nachdem ich von Beruf auch Schriftenmalerin bin, hab ich mich gemeldet.
David Boder: Was heißt Schrift...Schriftenmalerin?
Helen Tichauer: Das ist Malerei für Schilder.
David Boder: Nun?
Helen Tichauer: Nun bekam ich...
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie dann?
Helen Tichauer: Damals war ich zwei und zwanzig. Ich bekam rote Staubfarbe und einen Topf Firnis und einen Pinsel in die Hand gesteckt und mir wurde angeordnet die Farbe zu mischen. Und später wurden die Häftlinge vorgeführt und ich bekam den Befehl, eben den senkrechten Streifen an jeden einzelnen Häftling an...
David Boder: Oh, Sie mussten das machen während die Häftlinge die Kleider an hatten?
Helen Tichauer: . . . anzubringen, richtig.
David Boder: Aha.
Helen Tichauer: Nun so begann die Arbeit. Von Früh bis am Abend war ich voll beschäftigt. Ich musste den roten Streifen machen und jeder Häftling, der den roten Streifen hatte, war soweit in Ordnung. Der konnte [unverständlich] und konnte auch schon tätowiert werden.
David Boder: Ah, das war bevor dem Tätowieren?
Helen Tichauer: Ja. Jetzt, wie schon erwähnt, wurde uns doch eine Nummer an den Arm angebracht...an dem linken Unterarm. Um aber uns noch mehr...um uns noch besser zu erkennen und im Falle einer Kontrolle uns eigentlich zu erkennen, haben sie auf Stoff...haben sie auf Stoff im Männerlager—das schon damals eine Druckerei hatte, diese Nummern drucken lassen, die wir jetzt wieder auf den Arm tätowiert hatten. Um im Männerlager...um eben auf das Männerlager nicht angewiesen zu sein, bekam ich einen Druckapparat und ich habe auf...auf, hm, Streifen—auf Leinenstreifen Nummern von eins (21) bis sieben tausend (7000) oder acht tausend (8000), so viele waren ja damals, gedruckt. Ich wurde damals in das Büro rein gesteckt, das war das Aufnahmebüro, wo man jeden Häftling, der neu ankam, um seine Personalien fragte. Und automatisch jeder Häftling dann mit der ganzen Registrationsset—ihm wurde eine Nummer in die Hand gedrückt und er hatte die Pflicht sich die Nummer auf sein Kleid anzunähen.
David Boder: Das waren die Frauen?
Helen Tichauer: Das waren bloß Frauen.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Das Nummerndrucken hatte aber bei mir bald ein Ende genommen, denn inzwischen kamen andere Malerarbeiten. Ich musste Kleinigkeiten auf Schilder malen, musste Nummern auf einen Schrank für den Lagerführer malen, es war kleine, ziemlich unnütze Arbeit. Als ich...
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen die Anordnungen gegeben? Wer hat Ihnen gesagt, was Sie tun sollen?
Helen Tichauer: Der Lagerfuehrer.
David Boder: Das war ein SS?
Helen Tichauer: Ja, Stibetz. Im Anfang hatten wir...der Lagerfuehrer war eigentlich Führer des Frauenlagers und des Männerlagers. Ihm unterstand aber die Oberaufsicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Im Jahre zwei und vierzig (42) hatte die Oberaufsicht Frau Langenfeld. Als wir dann schon in Birkenau waren...
David Boder: Wie haben sie sich verhalten, wenn sie ihnen Befehle gegeben hat?
Helen Tichauer: Ganz normal. Wir mussten in einer Entfernung von drei (3) Metern stehen. Beim Eintritt...wir wurden vor gerufen. In dem Augenblick, wo wir den Raum dieser Oberaufseherin oder des Lagerführers betreten haben, mussten wir uns melden und zwar folgend—zum Beispiel: „Schutz-Häftling zwei und zwanzig sechs und achtzig (2286) bittet eintreten zu dürfen.“ Dann wurde der Eintritt bewilligt, dann bekam man einen Befehl. Angesprochen wurde man Teils per du, teils per du, je nachdem wie die Laune vorhanden war. Der Befehl wurde [unverständlich], das heißt er wurde gegeben und der Häftling hatte zu antworten: „Schutz-Häftling zwei und zwanzig sechs und achtzig (2286) bittet abtreten zu dürfen.“ So ging die Prozedur vor sich. Jetzt...im September neunzehn hundert zwei und vierzig (1942) war ich schon ungefähr zwei (2) oder drei (3) Wochen in Fieber. Zur Zeit als wir von Auschwitz nach Birkenau übersiedelten, hatte ich auch Fieber. Nur wussten wir, dass wir nicht krank sein dürfen...das hat man uns irgendwie ins Ohr geflüstert, dass man darf nicht krank sein. Also in meinem fiebrigen Zustand hab ich Nummern gedruckt, hab ich Streifen gemacht und hab meine Arbeit eben verrichtet. Ich hab damals zu Kommandoschreibstube als Zeichnerin gehört. Wurde auf einen Block verlegt, wo nicht nur Juden waren, sondern auch Juden, auch arische Häftlinge, denn die Juden wurden...jetzt in Birkenau gab es zwei Reihen. Auf der linken—links des Tor war ein Steinblock, wo früher einmal russische Kriegsgefangene waren. Von denen...von vierzig tausend (40000) damals, sie sich hier befanden, lebten nur noch zwei und dreißig (32).
David Boder: Was hat mit den Anderen passiert?
Helen Tichauer: Die Anderen sind...verreckt.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen?
Helen Tichauer: Verreckt in Sumpf und Schlamm. Das weiß ich daher...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie? Haben sie da gearbeitet?
Helen Tichauer: Haben hier gearbeitet. Das weiß ich von denen, die eben über...die damals...von den zwei und dreißig, die eben noch gelebt haben. Rechts dem Tor waren Holzbaracken. Es waren Pferdestall Baracken, wo die arischen Häftlinge untergebracht wurden—aus dem einfachen Grunde, weil diese Baracken reiner waren.
David Boder: Die Pferdeställe waren reiner...?
Helen Tichauer: Waren reiner. Und es gab Ausnahme-Blocks von solche Häftlinge, für solche Häftlinge,...für jüdische Häftlinge, die eine entsprechend notwendige Arbeit—damals hat man es für notwendig angesehen, Nummern zu drucken oder einen Steifen zu malen oder eventuell ein Geburtstagskärtchen zu zeichnen. Da hat man eben diese Häftlinge...
David Boder: Eine kleine Karte?
Helen Tichauer: Ein Kärtchen, ja. Da hat man diese Häftlinge gegeben auf den arischen Block. Ich bekam jede Nacht Schüttelfrost. Darauf wurde mein arischer Aufseher aufmerksam und zwang mich...
David Boder: Zwang Sie?
Helen Tichauer: . . . und zwang mich dem Lagerrevier—das war das Spital—zur Verfügung zu stellen. Meine Aufnahme erfolgte, nach drei (3) wöchigem Liegen—ohne Behandlung, ohne Medikamente—gab’s einen ganz komischen Tag für mich.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 149 with Helena Tichauer reporting. We are going over directly to Spool 150. Germany, September the 23rd, 1946 at Camp Feldafing, a large installation of the former Hitler Youth. I am here in the room with bare walls, apparently the paintings and so have been covered, [i.e.] the wall decorations. But the floor is of hardwood which could adorn any fine American home. There are about...I estimate fifteen to twenty acres of land, all with large barracks that the Hitler Youth occupied, and which is now occupied by about five thousand Jewish displaced persons. An Illinois Institute of technology wire recording. We are going over to Miss Helena Tichauer’s report [unintelligible] to the other spool.
David Boder: Germany, September the 23rd, 1946. Camp Feldafing near Munich. The interviewee is Mrs. Helena Tichauer, continuing from Spool 149. This is Spool 150. Mrs. Tichauer is continuing her report on her camp in Birkenau.
Helen Tichauer: Nun, dann im Jahre neunzehn hundert...
David Boder: Also im Jahr...
Helen Tichauer: In dem Jahr neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943)...im September, kam ich eben in dieses Lagerrevier, das war das Spital. Es war ein isolierter Block. Es war Block sieben und zwanzig (27), ein Stein Block, wo nur jüdische Häftlinge lagen—ohne Behandlung, ohne Medikamente, weil man eben Medikamente nicht für Juden zur Verfügung stellte. Man war drei Wochen hier fast ohne einen Tropfen Wasser und ohne normale Nahrung.
David Boder: Bitte, beschreiben Sie die Betten im Revier.
Helen Tichauer: Im jüdischen Steinblock gab’s ja keine Betten, nur sogenannte Kojen.
David Boder: Wie schreibt man das?
Helen Tichauer: K-O-J-E-N.
David Boder: Kojen.
Helen Tichauer: Kojen, richtig.
David Boder: Koyki, sagt man in polnisch.
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: In einer Höhe von drei (3) Metern...oder drei (3) Meter zwanzig (20) befanden sich drei (3) solche Löcher sozusagen. Es waren ganz einfache Höhlen, wo Platz für fünf (5) Mann, wenn’s schlecht ging—wenn’s gut ging [lacht etwas] auch für mehr war. Das ist die ungefähre Beschreibung.
David Boder: Ja. Waren das Holzgestelle?
Helen Tichauer: Der Block war ungefähr sieben und zwanzig (27) Meter lang. Es waren Stein Gestelle.
David Boder: Oh, Stein Geselle?
Helen Tichauer: Stein Gestelle...senkrecht. Waagrecht waren Holzgestelle.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Lang war eine solche Koje ein (1) Meter.
David Boder: Oh, das waren solche Pritschen?
Helen Tichauer: Richtig.
David Boder: Polati, hölzerne Plattform in russisch.
Helen Tichauer: So dass man liegen konnte, breit war sie ungefähr auch zwei (2) Meter. Hoch...also ungefähr zwei mal zwei (2 x 2). Drei solche Löcher waren oben eins auf den anderen.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Also das ist drei (3)Mal. Der Oberste war immer der Vorteilhafteste, weil oben bis zum Dach Luft und Platz war. Man hat die Leute je nach Bedarf da angebracht. Waren mehr Kranke, dann waren in einer solchen Koje fünf (5), sechs (6) bis acht (8) Leute auf...
David Boder: Alle neben einander?
Helen Tichauer: Alle neben einander wie Heringe. War mehr Platz, konnten drei (3) oder vier (4) liegen. Nun da lagen wir eben ganz verlassen. Die Leute lagen verlaust, verhungert und ungepflegt. Es kam der erste Oktober neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943). Durch das Fenster, es waren einige Fenster, vom Fenster aus sah man Lastauto hin und her fahren. Später erfuhren wir, dass neben—hinter Block sieben und zwanzig (27), sechs und zwanzig (26) und dann Block fünf und zwanzig (25) wegfahren. Block fünf und zwanzig (25) war der bekannte Isolations Block. Da wurden halb kranke, halb erschöpfte, fast ganz erschöpfte Mädchen aufgesammelt und alle Tage ging ein Transport mit Lastwagen von solchen Mädchen weg. Es hieß, man geht nach Lublin. Aber als nach einer Stunde die selben Kleider, das heißt die alten Uniformen mit den Nummern, mit den angenähten Nummern zurück kamen, wussten wir genau, dass man Menschen nicht nackt nach Lublin transportieren kann. Und es dauerte nicht lange bis wir erfuhren die Nachricht, dass Männer vom Sonderkommando, dass die Menschen vergast wurden. Am ersten (1.) Oktober schickte man alle kranken Häftlinge, die im Block sieben und zwanzig (27), wo ich lag, befanden vor den Block. Sie wurden aufgefordert sich neben einander zu setzen. Es waren damals sieben hundert (700) Mädchen auf dem Block, kranke Mädchen, krank teilweise an Fleckfieber, teilweise an Malaria, an Infektionen und was eben noch dazwischen kam.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gehabt?
Helen Tichauer: Ich?
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Ich hatte damals Fleckfieber. Ich...
David Boder: Mit anderen Leuten nebenbei, die was hatten?
Helen Tichauer: Dies eben...Malaria und...so kleine Infektionen.
David Boder: Alle auf der selben Pritsche?
Helen Tichauer: Alles in einem Block.
David Boder: Nein, nein...alle auf...
Helen Tichauer: Alle von der selben Koje, richtig. Jetzt wurden wir aufgefordert uns draußen vor dem Block zu versammeln, halb erschöpft, kalt war es. Drei (3) oder vier (4) Stunden lang saß man. Inzwischen sind aber vorbei an unseren Augen dutzendweise Lastautos mit Mädchen aus dem Tor hinaus.
David Boder: [unverständlich; man hört Dr. Boder fast nicht]
Helen Tichauer: Nein, es waren normale Wehrmachts...
David Boder: Oh, dutzendweise?
Helen Tichauer: Dutzendweise, ja, aus dem Tor hinaus—Richtung zum weißen Haus. Damals waren schon 2 Krematorien nach moderner Ausführung errichtet und tätig. Im Laufe der nächsten Monate sind alle—sind die restlichen...zwei (2), drei (3) eigentlich beendet worden und die dann Tag und Nacht mit Volldampf arbeiteten, als später Tausende von Judentransporten aus allen Ländern Europas kamen.
David Boder: Nun haben Sie so ein Krematorium gesehen?
Helen Tichauer: Ja. , aber...
David Boder: Wie viele Leute kann man zu einer Zeit verbrennen?
Helen Tichauer: Eines weiß ich, an unserem Tor fuhren,...kam ein Transport von tausend Menschen...und es war immer so, dass zehn(10) Prozent nur ins Lager kamen, das ist hundert (100) von tausend (1000). Und neun hundert (900) bestehend aus Müttern mit Kindern—ob jung oder al, war egal—wenn ein Kind am Arm oder an der Hand geführt wurde, wurde man als Mutter betrachtet.
David Boder: Als was?
Helen Tichauer: Als Mutter.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Mutter, Kind, ältere, kränkliche Menschen. Ich möchte eigentlich später noch darauf zurück kommen, wie eine solche Sortierung vor sich ging, weil ich...
David Boder: Ja. Aber wir wollen darauf zurück kommen was mit Ihnen war.
Helen Tichauer: Kommen wir zurück. An dem ersten Oktober gingen dutzendweise die Lastautos an unserem Augen vorbei. Erst später, als ich...
David Boder: Nun wollen wir dabei bleiben, was ist mit Ihnen passiert?
Helen Tichauer: Gut, richtig. Dann kam die Reihe auf uns. Es kam Ohrmeier. Der Name des Lagerführers...er hieß Müller. So kam Herr Müller auf uns zu und sagte, dass alles, was er bis jetzt hergegeben hat, ist ihm zu wenig. Das hörte ich mit eigenen Ohren. Ich war damals in den ganzen Dingen nicht mehr naiv, denn ich habe teilweise, während der Zeit ich noch nicht im Revier lag, in der Schreibstube gearbeitet und ich weiß nur, dass wir dort ständig bekommen haben Totenlisten—von denen, die auf Autos geladen wurden und dann nicht mehr zum Vorschein kamen. Damals sagte er nur, sagte Herr Ohrmeier nur, es wäre ihm zu wenig. Block fünf und zwanzig (25) war leer. Gesunde Frauen, die bis auf drei tausend ungefähr—nach meiner Schätzung damals in dem Cargo Zustand waren sind in den Tod hinaus gefahren. Jetzt kommt die Reihe an uns.
David Boder: Gesunde Frauen wurden verladen?
Helen Tichauer: Gesunde Frauen, ja. Herr Lagerfuehrer Müller wurde durch seine Sekretärin, die damals wegen Rassenschande bei uns arbeitete und war ein Häftling und sie war Anni Meier—Anni Meier wurde damals darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass ich mich auch unter diesen Häftlingen befinde, die da auf Block sieben und zwanzig sind. Und ich hab vor meiner Krankheit für den Lagerfuehrer ein paar Nummern auf einen Kasten gemalt, aber konnte sie nicht mehr beenden. Da kam er auf mich zu und fragte mich, was ich da mach. Ich antwortete, ich wäre fieberfrei und würde wieder arbeiten wollen. Da sagte er mir: „Gut, dann gehen Sie mal gegenüber, da ist die arische Ambulanz. Lassen Sie sich Ihr Fieber messen und wenn Sie keines mehr haben, dann bleiben Sie. Haben Sie welches, dann gehen Sie mit.“ Oft...auf der arischen Ambulanz arbeitete damals eine Schwester...
David Boder: Mit Ambulanz meinen Sie eine Klinik?
Helen Tichauer: Ja. Das war eine Holzbaracke—eine Kleine.
David Boder: Ja, sehen Sie, wir nennen eine Ambulanz ein Auto.
Helen Tichauer: Eine Klinik, sozusagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Dort arbeitet eine deutsche Krankenschwester, eine politische Deutsche, die ungefähr acht (8) Jahre schon da war und mit der ich vorher einen kleinen Kontakt hatte. Die arbeitet da und sie wusste genau worum es geht. Und sie hat mir versichert, wenn ich sagte: „Zippi, auch wenn Du jetzt drei und vierzig (43) Grad Fieber hast, ich sag nichts.“
David Boder: Wie hat sie zu Ihnen gesagt? Zippe?
Helen Tichauer: Zippi heiß ich, so hat man mich genannt.
David Boder: Z...?
Helen Tichauer: Z-I-P-P-I.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Sie selbst hat...hm, der Name ist mir momentan entfallen. Ich werde später darauf zurück kommen. Und wirklich nach fünf (%) Minute kam Herr Müller und er hatte den Bericht ich wäre fieberfei. Ich...
David Boder: Waren Sie?
Helen Tichauer: Ich war nicht fieberfrei. Ich bekam Baldrian, um mich zu beruhigen und musste drei Stunden lang noch da sitzen und warten.
David Boder: Draußen?
Helen Tichauer: In dem Zimmer. Und durch das Fenster sah ich dann alle meine...meine Mädchen, mit denen ich lag beisammen da krank lag, auf den Wagen und sie beim Tor hinaus führen. Ich wurde sofort aufgefordert meine Arbeit in der Schreibstube anzutreten. Fiebernd, halb blind, halb [unverständlich] nach einem Typhus, trat ich meine Arbeit an. Ich hatte damals kaum siebzig (70) Pfund.
David Boder: Wieviel wiegen Sie jetzt?
Helen Tichauer: Jetzt habe ich zwei und fünfzig (52).
David Boder: Zwei und fünfzig (52) Kilo?
Helen Tichauer: Zwei und fünfzig (52) Kilo und das heißt hundert vier Pfund. Das Bewusstsein, dass ich als einzige Überlebende an diesem Tag von vier tausend Mädchen zurück blieb, gab mir Kraft und den Glauben an ein weiteres Durchhalten. Hundert (100) prozentig war ich sicher, dass die Mädchen vergast wurden, darum, weil wir in der Schreibstube außerhalb der Namenkartothek ein Nummernbuch eingeführt hatten.
David Boder: Ein Nummernbuch?
Helen Tichauer: Ein Nummernbuch—und jeder Häftling, welcher starb, verstarb...wurde mit einem schwarzen...mit einem roten Kreuz bezeichnet—jede Nummer. Und solche Häftlinge, welche vergast wurden, mit einem schwarzen Kreuz. Somit hatte ich schwarz auf weiß das, was passiert war. Nach Wochen erholte ich mich. Inzwischen aber gingen noch täglich Transporte von den Mädchen aus dem Lager. Und im Februar neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943), wo die Zahl—die Häftlingsnummer des letzten Häftlings, des letzten Ankömmlings drei und dreißig tausend erreichte, davon vielleicht schon über zwanzig tausend Juden waren, blieben nach einer großen Selektion im Februar tausend fünf hundert (1500).
David Boder: Februar von welchem Jahr?
Helen Tichauer: . . . drei und vierzig (‚43)...tausend fünf hundert jüdische Häftlinge, Frauen Häftlinge.
David Boder: Wann?
Helen Tichauer: Im Februar drei und vierzig (’43). Die Gesamtzahl betrug damals ungefähr um sieben tausend (7000). Das, was nicht vergast wurde, sind am Typhus zu Grunde—ohne Behandlung, ohne Medikamente—sind teilweise an Hunger zu Grunde gegangen. Es war damals sogar eine große Selektion von nicht-jüdischen Häftlingen.
David Boder: Was ist eine Selektion?
Helen Tichauer: Eine Selektion ist wie eine Auslese, eine natürliche Auslese, die mit dem Fremdwort Selektion bedacht ist. Das war keine natürliche Auslese, das war eine Auslese der SS.
David Boder: Wie haben sie diese Leute ausgesucht?
Helen Tichauer: Sie haben beurteilt nach Laune, nach Aussehen, ob jemand noch arbeitsfähig oder lebensfähig ist oder nicht. Es gab einen General Appell an diesem...ich denke es war der neunzehnte (19.) Februar. Ein General Appell war ein Appell, wo das ganze Lager gegenüber auf einer Wiese versammelt wurde.
David Boder: Wer?
Helen Tichauer: Bloß Frauen, und dann einzeln ins Lager rein gelassen wurden. Nach links und nach rechts. Diese...diese Selektion wurde damals Oberaufseherin Maria Mandelbein und die damalige Arbeitsdienst Führerin Hasse, die Schwester der Aufseherin Franz Dicolette im Lager Mühldorf, in das Frauenlager Mühldorf ist gefahren Eine ging nach links und Eine ging nach rechts. Und alles was nach links ging, ging zum Block 25. Damals gingen nicht nur jüdische Frauen; es gingen zum Grossteil Jugoslawinnen, selbst Reichsdeutsche Diebe [unverständlich], Reichsdeutsche politische Häftlinge, Reichsdeutsche asoziale Häftlinge, Russinnen, alles was eben vorhanden war. Es wurde keine Rücksicht darauf genommen, ob jüdisch oder nicht jüdisch. Es war aber dann damals der letzte Arier, der vergast wurde. Dann kamen weitere Befehle aus Berlin, denn die Aufseherinnen oder SS Angehörige haben Selektionen nur dann gemacht, wenn Berlin angeordnet hat eine Selektion durchzuführen. Ich werde da ein Beispiel bringen: es gab, zum Beispiel, zwei tausend (2000) Typhus Fälle im Spital. Das Lager hat Berlin angefragt, ob es gestattet ist von den zwei tausend (2000) Typhus Fällen , alle von den zwei tausend jüdischen Typhus Fällen die Mädchen zu vergasen. Nach drei (3) Monaten ungefähr kam die Antwort „ja“. Inzwischen waren vielleicht schon vierzig Prozent (40%) dieser Mädchen schon gesund. Aber die Zahl zwei tausend musste aufgebracht werden. Man hat alle Jüdinnen aus dem Spital, die da lagen—ohne Ausnahme—ob sie jetzt Krätze oder bloß eine andere Kleinigkeit hatten, genommen, denn der Rest , der von den zwei tausend (2000) fehlte, weil der schon entlassen war, weil die schon gesund waren—wurde dadurch auch auf diese Art aufgebracht, indem man in die Blocks ging. Die SS ging in die Blocks und diesmal gefiel ihnen vielleicht nur der Stubendienst, der gut aussah. Sie nahmen den gesunden Stubendienst. Sie nahmen die Mädchen, die eben auf der Landstrasse zur Toilette eilten. Sie nahmen, was ihnen in den Weg gang. Die Nummer zwei tausend war erreicht. Es war aber noch nicht genug. Sie haben diesmal eine Einzelaktion ausgenützt und die Nummer ging gleich auf drei tausend. Und diese Mädchen gingen auch ins Gas. Ich weiß es, denn ich hab die Nummern laut Liste, die wir bekamen, im Nummernbuch schwarz angezeichnet.
David Boder: Ja, aber es hat niemand im Nummernbuch gesagt, was schwarz —was es bedeutet.
Helen Tichauer: Doch. Wir wussten: SB—Sonderbehandlung.
David Boder: Hm. Das war der Name dafür?
Helen Tichauer: Das war der Name.
David Boder: Es sagt nicht vergast?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, es sagt immer wieder ‚Sonderbehandlung’. Das Kommando hieß auch Sonderkommando, die dabei arbeiteten. Und vergast durften dann auf Befehl Berlin nur solche Juden werden, die mit RSHA Transporten kamen; also verlockte Juden.
David Boder: Was heißt RSHA?
Helen Tichauer: Reichs-Sicherheits-Hauptamt Berlin. Juden, die aus dem Gefängnis kamen, wurden als kartei-mäßige Juden behandelt. Sie wurden Kartei-mäßig aufgenommen, ihre Kleider...
David Boder: Was heißt das ‚Kartei...’?
Helen Tichauer: Kartothek, es wurde eine Kartothek ihrer Kleider angelegt, die sie aber niemals zu sehen bekamen und waren vor einem Vergasen, vor einer Sonderbehandlung geschützt. Das war der einzige Vorteil. Nun, wenn aber dazu kam, dass irrtümlicherweise ein solcher Jude von so einem Transport ins Gas ging, dann wurde eben eine Totenmeldung ausgestellt—eine Totenmeldung—akuter Darmkatarrh und etc.
David Boder: Nun, die, hm , Kartei, was haben Sie da gesagt?
Helen Tichauer: Kartei-mäßige Juden und daher...
David Boder: Kartei-mäßige Juden waren solche, die nicht vergast wurden?
Helen Tichauer: Die nicht vergast werden sollten. Und daher kommt es heute zum Grossteil, wenn wir vielleicht ältere Menschen, wenn wir vielleicht schwache, kränkliche Menschen sehen, die heute leben, dank dessen, dass sie kartei-mäßige Häftlinge doch im Gefängnis waren. Sie waren bevorzugt. Es war eigentlich paradox.
David Boder: Was?
Helen Tichauer: Denn die Leute, die aus dem Gefängnis kamen, haben sich bestimmt bewusst was zu Schulden kommen lassen. Die Anderen kamen ganz harmlos und unschuldig ins Lager, nur darum, weil sie Juden waren.
David Boder: Also die sogenannten Kriminellen sind am Leben geblieben.
Helen Tichauer: Richtig. Zum Grossteil oder sie wurden entweder ausgepeitscht zu Tode, bei der Arbeit erschlagen. Das ist dann schon, da waren es nicht nur Juden. So wurden...so endeten auch viele andere, Tausende auch von anderen, nicht-jüdischen Häftlingen. Haben Sie noch eine Frage?
David Boder: Nun also was war da weiter? Wie ist es Ihnen gegangen? Ich will das eindeutig wissen.
Helen Tichauer: Also ich arbeitete dann in der Schreibstube. Meine Arbeit bestand...dadurch, dass ich dann nach meiner Krankheit dem Lagerführer die paar Nummern an seinem Schrank beendete und ich als Einzige von vier tausend (4000) Frauen kam, wurde...wurde man auf mich aufmerksam. Die SS, die sich damals—die entlassen wurde oder versetzt wurde—und eine Neue kam, wusste immer wieder von den Anderen, dieser Häftling wurde von Herrn Müller bevorzugt. Sie wussten nicht warum. Und wenn es dann später zu irgendwelchen Selektionen kam, da haben sie auf mich vergessen. Ausserdem habe ich dann schon im Laufe der Zeit Arbeiten, die keine zweite (2.) Frau durch geführt hat, weil ich eben ein Fachmann war. [unverständlich] waren sie, zum Beispiel, auch gut aussehende Kartothek, oft Kleinigkeiten, die ich ihnen immer wieder auf Befehl durch geführt hab, genau so wie jeder andere Häftling seine Arbeit verrichtet hat, die ihm anbefohlen wurde.
David Boder: Nun, wie ist es weiter gegangen dann?
Helen Tichauer: Dann später habe ich in der Schreibstube als Häftling gearbeitet, gearbeitet teilweise bei der Kartothek teilweise..., also immer wieder das gemacht, was nötig war. Dann kam Obersturmführer Hessler, Hessler, der im Bergen-Belsen Prozess erhängt wurde. Er wurde unser Lagerführer.
David Boder: In...in Birkenau?
Helen Tichauer: Ja. Ich [unverständlich]...ich möchte sagen noch Einiges über Hessler—einige Worte sagen. Die Selektionen, die durch geführt wurden bei Ankunft eines Transportes, wo ich schon erwähnt habe, dass 90% ins Krematorium gingen, dem wohnte auch Herr Hessler bei. Mal Herr Hessler, mal Herr Dr. Mengele, mal Frau Oberaufseher Mandel, mal auch Oberaufseher Drexel, je nach dem —abwechselnd. Das ging so automatisch, rechts, links, wer eben Glück hatte, der kam ins Lager. Und nur diejenigen, die ins Lager kamen, wurden tätowiert, bekamen ihre Nummer und wurden in der Kartothek eingetragen. Herr Hessler beteiligte sich auch an diesen Selektionen, genau so wie alle anderen SS Angehörigen. Aber Tausende von männlichen und weiblichen Häftlingen können heute Herrn Hessler vielleicht ihr Leben verdanken. Denn er war derjenige, der eine ganz radikale Durchführung der Entlausung vor sich nahm. In allen Lagern—Männer- und Frauenlager—die Typhuslaus verschwand. Und Häftlinge blieben auf diese Art vom Typhus verschont.
David Boder: Wie hat er das gemacht?
Helen Tichauer: Er hat die Kleider in Dampfkessel stecken lassen, wo die Typhuslaus eben getötet wurde, die Eier, die Brut getötet wurde. Die Häftlinge wurden oftmals geschoren, Haare, wo er eben Haare hatte und machte nach dem Bad eine Reinigung durch und hat sich da, hat auch da genügend Seife und Wasser zur Verfügung gestellt und solche Entlausungen fanden jeden Monat statt. Also es gab keinen Häftling in Birkenau, der sich nicht einmal im Monat einer Entlausung unterzogen wurde.
David Boder: Aha.
Helen Tichauer: Und eben Hessler hat damals...wurde also genau so, wie alle Anderen, wurde auch auf mich aufmerksam als Lagerzeichnerin, hat mir Farben zur Verfügung gestellt und hat mir einen kleinen Raum neben der Schreibstube eingerichtet, wo ich gearbeitet habe. Ich habe damals die...den ersten größeren Auftrag bekommen ein Diagramm durch zu führen. Ein Diagramm des Arbeitseinsatzes, das heißt, alles was sich im Lager abgespielt hat, die tägliche Veränderung der Stärke, die täglichen Zugänge, Arbeitseinsatz in Rüstungsindustrie, in...in der Landwirtschaft und überall, wo Häftlinge gearbeitet haben in Form eines Diagrammes monatlich aufzustellen, das dann nach Berlin abging. Ich hab dieses Diagramm einmal für ihn und einmal für mich gemacht. Und den nächsten Tag, den achtzehnten (18.) Januar fünf und vierzig (45) hab ich eine Rolle von Duplikaten hinter dem Schrank im Lager Birkenau, Abschnitt B 2 B, geworfen. Ich glaube, es ist in die Hände der Russen gefallen.
David Boder: Sie wissen nicht in welche Hände es gefallen ist?
Helen Tichauer: Nein.
David Boder: Warum konnten Sie es selber nicht nehmen?
Helen Tichauer: Ich konnte es selber nicht...wieso denn? Wir mussten ja evakuieren.
David Boder: Ach Sie wurden evakuiert?
Helen Tichauer: Ja und ich...man hat eben vorher alle Papiere, die ganzen Hauptbücher alle verbrannt. Und von diesen Diagrammen wusste keiner. Ich hab sie hinter den Schrank geworfen.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie diese Diagramme hinter den Schrank geworfen? Also weiter.
Helen Tichauer: Ja, um die Zeit irgendwie tot zu schlagen, hab ich in diesem kleinen Raum mir vorgenommen das Lager Birkenau plastisch aufzubauen. Die entsprechenden Utensilien und alles was eben dazu gehörte, habe ich mir besorgt.
David Boder: Geschlafen haben Sie im allgemeinen Block?
Helen Tichauer: Geschlafen habe ich mit allen Häftlingen beisammen. Bevorzugt war ich nicht, Bindenträger war ich auch keiner. Ich war bloß anerkannt als Lagerzeichnerin.
David Boder: Was haben Sie zu essen bekommen?
Helen Tichauer: Zu essen? Genau das selbe wie jeder andere Häftling. In der Früh gab es Kaffee, dann gab es täglich fünf hundert (500) Gramm...nein, ich weiß nicht genau, aber es war ein...von einem...von zwei (2) Pfund Brot war es ein Viertel. Das heißt doch 500 Gramm so.
David Boder: Von zwei (2) Kilo?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, von zwei (2) Pfund...von einem Kilo Brot, 250 Gramm.
David Boder: Gramm?
Helen Tichauer: Es hat sich doch jedes Mal gewechselt. Einmal war das Brot auf vier (4), ein anderes Mal für fünf (5).
David Boder: Was für ein Brot war das?
Helen Tichauer: Es war ein Wehrmachtsbrot.
David Boder: War es lange bevor gebacken?
Helen Tichauer: Es wird jeden Tag gebacken. Auschwitz, das Männerlager Auschwitz hatte eine Bäckerei.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Das Lager Auschwitz war an und für sich autonom. Die verschiedensten Werkstätten, verschiedensten...
David Boder: War da eine, hm, eine...eine Gasfabrik in der Nähe?
Helen Tichauer: Eine Gasfabrik?
David Boder: Eine Fabrik, die diese Gase gemacht hat.
Helen Tichauer: Nein, das Gas war in Büchsen und hieß Zyklon.
David Boder: Ja. Nun weiter.
Helen Tichauer: Diese Büchsen sah man manchmal, denn sie waren—zur Zeit für Entlausung wurden sie auch verwendet. Es wurde aber bei der Entlausung mit Gas mehr gespart wie bei der Vergasung der Menschen, das wissen wir.
David Boder: Es wurde mehr gespart?
Helen Tichauer: Mehr gespart. Alles war immer wieder ausgerechnet, aber es genügte für die Läuse.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Nun wo war ich? Nun, dann...Ja, ich habe beschlossen das Lager plastisch aufzustellen. Und tatsächlich nach drei (3) monatiger Arbeit mit noch einem Häftling, die mir dabei geholfen hat, haben wir das Lager Birkenau auf einer Fläche von zwei (2) Meter mal achtzig (80) hergestellt. Nachher kam es unter Glas und wurde auf die Kommandantur zwei (2) getragen. Ich hab den Plan heute noch im Kopf. Denn die Bauleitung, die damals Pläne und dergleichen fachmännisch durchführte, war immer voll beschäftigt und immer wieder wollten die Herren von dem Lager, der Lagerführer und der Rapportführer schematische Pläne haben. Sie haben ja auch eher schematische Pläne verstanden.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Helen Tichauer: Und da kamen sie zu mir und so beschäftigten sie mich halt.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie gezeichnet...mit Tusche, Tinte, oder?
Helen Tichauer: Ich habe mir immer das Notwendigste besorgt. Alles war vorhanden, denn es kamen auch Zeichner, es kamen auch Künstler mit den Transporten, die nicht mehr das Glück hatten ins Lager zu kommen, aber die Dinge von ihnen blieben übrig und sie wurden in einem Lager, das Effekten Lager Brezinki—neben—es war in mitten aller Krematorien ein Lager, getarnt mit Bäumen, wo Baracken...wo es Baracken gab, in welchen die Kleider und alles, was eben die Leute mit sich brachten, aufgestapelt war und eben von da habe ich mir diese Dinge geholt.
David Boder: Nun—wann kamen Sie...wo sind Sie nach Auschwitz gegangen?
Helen Tichauer: Es kam der achtzehnte (18.) Januar.
David Boder: Fünf und vierzig.
Helen Tichauer: Fünf und vierzig. Von weitem hörten wir schon es sind Detonationen. Wir wussten ganz genau, es sind die Russen. Das letzte Krematorium flog in die Luft bei Anordnung der SS. Die ersten vier wurden von den Häftlingen, die da selbst...also vom Sonderkommando das hier die ganze Zeit die Leute verbrennen musste, wurden die Krematorium, die Krematorien demoliert.
David Boder: Das wurde ihnen befohlen?
Helen Tichauer: Wurde ihnen von Berlin aus befohlen. Je näher die Russen kamen, umso rascher wurde gearbeitet. Und am letzten Tag war keine Zeit mehr. Wir mussten weg und das Krematorium fliegt in the Luft. Die Häftlinge...
David Boder: Wann hat man aufgehört die Leute zu vergasen?
Helen Tichauer: Zu vergasen hat man aufgehört Ende Oktober fünf und vierzig (45).
David Boder: Vier und vierzig (44).
Helen Tichauer: Vier und vierzig (44) auf Anordnung Berlin. Und die nächsten Transporte, die nach...die danach kamen, egal of Kinder, ob Alte, wurden nicht mehr vergast. Es gibt heute noch ganze Familien, die damals das Glück hatten zu kommen und zu überleben. Hauptsächlich slowakische Transporte kamen damals. Und die letzten Transporte, wo ich selbst aus meiner Familie kleine Kinder hatte, wurden nicht vergast und blieben am Leben.
David Boder: Nun hat ihre Familie überlebt?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, es sind bloß Verwandte gewesen.
David Boder: Ich meine Ihre Familie.
Helen Tichauer: Meine Eltern selbst, weiß ich von Leuten, die dann nachträglich zu uns kamen, mit den nachfolgenden Transporten in dem Jahre drei und vierzig (43), dass sie mit dem Familientransport nach Lublin abgefahren wären und was wir wissen von diesem Transport genau lebt keiner. In der Tschechoslowakei, das heißt in der Slowakei, wurden sechzig tausend (60000) Juden deportiert. Von diesen sechzig tausend (60000) leben hundert fünfzig (150) Männer und vier hundert fünfzig (450) Mädchen.
David Boder: Aus der Tschechoslowakei.
Helen Tichauer: Aus der Slowakei.
David Boder: Wie wissen Sie diese Zahlen?
Helen Tichauer: Wieso? Denn die ganzen Mädchen kamen mit mir. Die Lubliner Transporte haben es nicht überlebt und alle anderen Transporte kamen zu uns. Und der Stand...wir haben täglich Nationalitäten Aufstellungen gemacht, die ich teilweise so regis...so einzuteilen hatte, ja. Der Stand im letzten Monat...der Stand bei den Mädchen vier hundert fünfzig (450), der Slowakinnen.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mal, was hat dann passiert? Die Russen kamen näher, das Krematorium flog in die Luft.
Helen Tichauer: In die Luft.
David Boder: Und was ist mit Ihnen passiert?
Helen Tichauer: Und man hat die Auschwitzer Männer Häftlinge und Frauen Häftlinge evakuiert.
David Boder: Und Sie waren darunter.
Helen Tichauer: Und ich war darunter.
David Boder: Wo hat man Sie evakuiert und wie hat man Sie evakuiert?
Helen Tichauer: Wir gingen direkt in Richtung Loslau.
David Boder: Zu Fuß?
Helen Tichauer: Zu Fuß. In der größten...
David Boder: Männer und Frauen zusammen?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, begleitet von SS. Vierzig tausend (40000) Häftlinge ungefähr, schätzungweise sind damals niedergeschossen worden, weil...
David Boder: Wo?
Helen Tichauer: Auf dem Weg, wenn wir...
David Boder: Wie viele Häftlinge haben denn Auschwitz verlassen?
Helen Tichauer: Über hundert tausend (100000).
David Boder: Hundert tausend (100000) auf einmal?
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Helen Tichauer: Und wir sahen tote Häftlinge links und recht, vorne, die Männer, die vor uns gingen wurden zum Grossteil nieder geknallt und wir gingen an den Leichen vorbei. Die SS war damals speziell für die die ausgesucht [unverständlich]...zum Grossteil Volksdeutsche, eine großer Teil Volk...
David Boder: Volksdeutsche, wer waren die?
Helen Tichauer: Volksdeutsche, Volksdeutsche sind alle Deutschen, die nicht Reichsdeutsch sind, die sich deutsch national fühlen, bekennen, aber nicht reichsdeutsch.
David Boder: Nicht in Deutschland geboren?
Helen Tichauer: Also jugoslawische Deutsche, Sudetendeutsche.
David Boder: Aha. Sudentendeutsche.
Helen Tichauer: Und Ukrainer. [unverständlich] Deutsche und so weiter, und so weiter...Alles was...
David Boder: Und sie gehörten zur SS?
Helen Tichauer: Diese SS Angehörigen...
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Die Volksdeutschen waren zum Grossteil ärger wie alle Anderen. Wir wurden von denen gejagt, mal nach Norden, mal nach Süden, mal nach Osten, mal nach Westen. Wir konnten uns dieses Hin- und Herjagen nicht erklären, denn es war doch in dem Interesse, dass wir vorwärts kommen, wir haben uns ja von den Russen gejagt. Bloß waren wir an einem Ort, dann hieß es die Russen sind fünf (5) Kilometer entfernt, so jetzt muss man nach südwärts; waren wir dann da gewesen, mussten wir nordwärts. Und so kamen wir erschöpft nach Tag und Nacht in der Stadt Wroclaw, Ober Schlesien an, wo wir in Wagons—in offene Viehwagons im Januar—zu hundert in Einen eingepfercht wurden.
David Boder: Nun beschreiben Sie die Reise.
Helen Tichauer: Die Reise ging Tag und Nacht, hin und her eigentlich. Genau so wie der Weg zu Fuß , auch die Reise mit dem Zug, ohne Verpflegung, im Sturm, ohne Toiletten, ohne nichts.
David Boder: Doch, wer hat sie bewacht?
Helen Tichauer: Bewacht von der SS. Man fuhr mit uns—man fuhr—man wusste nicht genau wohin.
David Boder: Doch, sie haben ja wirklich ohne Essen gewesen während dieser Zeit?
Helen Tichauer: Ohne zu essen, denn es war ein Befehl, dass für ungefähr hundert (100) Mann, für hundert (100) Frauen, die sich in einem Wagon befanden zwei (2) Brote und eine Dose Konservenfleisch verteilt werden sollten. Das wurde aber auch...fünfzig (50) Prozent davon wurde verteilt an die SS, weil die SS selbst war hungrig.
David Boder: Nun?
Helen Tichauer: Wir haben am ersten Tag eine dünne Scheibe Brot und vielleicht ein hundert Gramm Fleisch bekommen.
David Boder: Jeder?
Helen Tichauer: Jeder. Und der Rest bestand aus Schnee, den wir geleckt haben, weil er eben fiel. Dann später in der Nähe von Berlin, wusste die Bevölkerung nicht genau, wer wir sind und da brachten sie uns heißen Kaffee oder heißes Wasser.
David Boder: Die Bevölkerung.
Helen Tichauer: Die Bevölkerung. Wir selbst fuhren in Richtung Oranienburg. Und mir war das ziemlich bekannt, ich wusste ganz genau, wo sich die einzelnen Konzentrationslager noch befinden.
David Boder: Wieso wussten Sie das?
Helen Tichauer: Wieso? Denn wir selbst in der Schreibstube haben ja doch Häftlinge manchmal überstellt. Dann kamen Häftlinge von einem in ein anderes Lager. Wir haben immer kalkuliert, wo ungefähr was liegt. Ich wusste genau, wenn der Weg nach Oranienburg geht, dann führt uns der Weg nach Ravensbrück...und Ravensbrück ist ein bekanntes, deutsches Konzentrationslager gewesen.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Ravensbrueck...ich weiß nicht, ich möcht noch bevor auf Ravensbrueck zurück komme, einen Fall erwähnen.
Helen Tichauer: In Auschwitz gab es Häftlinge, die für experimentelle Zwecke zur Verfügung gestellt wurden, das heißt gezwungen wurden. Es gab im Männerlager...im Männerlager ein Block zehn (10), das war Block zehn (10). Block zehn (10) befand sich neben Block 11, der sogenannte Bunker, wo Tausend von Exekutionen stattfanden, die ich oftmals durch die Spalte einiger Holzbretter sehen konnte.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Helen Tichauer: Zum Beispiel, es war doch damals, wie wir in Auschwitz waren...es war so. Man konnte sehen, der Häftling wurde raus gejagt nach links. Dann hörte man einen Knall. Wie wir erfuhren danach, es war ein Genickschuss und rechts kann man...konnte man durch die Spalte...Berge....Haufen von warmen Menschenleichen noch sehen. Zur damaligen Zeit schoss Herr Haupttruppenführer Barich. Sein Nachbar, das war Herr Stiebitz auf dem Block zehn (10). Selbst bin ich nicht gewesen auf dem Block zehn (10) zur Zeit, wo Experimente durchgeführt wurden. Block zehn 10) hatte das Bestreben künstliche Befruchtung durchzuführen. Soll ich erzählen?
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Ich hoffe, es...Sie werden die Möglichkeit haben durch persönliche Zeugen über den Block zehn (10) Einiges zu erfahren.
David Boder: Wir können beginnen hier.
Helen Tichauer: Jetzt Ravensbrück, als ich in Ravensbrück ankam, habe ich was anderes gehört und es stimmt. Frauen, hauptsächlich Polinnen, wurden auch in den Isolierblock gesteckt, denen dann Rippen entfernt und sie damit zum Krüppel machte, um die an deutschen Kriegsverwundeten zu ersetzen.
David Boder: Nun wie kann man Frauenrippen Männern...?
Helen Tichauer: Es müssen nicht Rippen gewesen sein, es können Knochen, ein Schienbein, es kann ein anderer Teil damals gewesen sein, jedenfalls stimmt es.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Die Frauen wurden aber dann nicht mehr als Krüppel entlassen. Ravensbrück hatte auch sein Krematorium. Es gibt eben auch hier ein anderes Mittel, um den Menschen eben...zu töten. Es gab Spritzen, es gab verschiedene andere Dinge über die Sie von Zeugen, vielleicht von Ärzten, die vielleicht selbst dort gearbeitet haben, erfahren werden. Ravensbrück machte auf mich persönlich den Eindruck, wie vielleicht Auschwitz in neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943)—ein Chaos, ein Durcheinander, Schmutz, Hunger, ein Gejage. Die SS wusste nicht mehr was mit uns zu beginnen. Wir wurden weiter transportiert—weg...jetzt in kleinere Lager, die für ein tausend Mann bloß bestimmt waren und keine drei Tausend. Man kann sich vorstellen, wie dann die Wohn- und Essverhältnisse ausgesehen haben, bis zum Tage der Befreiung. Und dann...
David Boder: Wann wurden Sie befreit und von wem?
Helen Tichauer: Bitte warten Sie. Der Tag der Befreiung...es war der dritte Mai.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool hundred and...150. Miss Helena Tichauer...Miss Helena...Mrs. Helena Tichauer. She started her record...her report on 149, and we are going over to the third...we are going over to the third spool of her report.
David Boder: Germany, September the 23rd, 1946. Feldafing Camp, about 30 kilometers or so from Munich, a camp for displaced Jews. Located on about a 20 acre or so reservation, if we could call it [that]. Full with two-story buildings, now with additional temporary buildings also, in which Hitler Youth was getting its preliminary training. The interviewee is Miss Helena Tichauer, otherwise Zippi genannt [called], and we are now here to the final wanderings which so often come through, where...where prisoners of war or concentration camp inhabitants were carried around and chased around [by the Germans] from one place to the other for some reason that they should not get into the hands either of the Americans or the Russians.
David Boder: [In German] Also wohin kamen Sie nach diesem Wandern, Frau Tichauer?
Helen Tichauer: Das letzte Lager nach Ravensbrück war ein kleines Arbeitslager Malchow, das nicht mehr lange dauerte, denn eine Woche vor...zwei Wochen bevor Kriegsende hat das rote schwedische Kreuz—das rote, schwedischen Kreuz genommen—eigentlich, Autos geschickt und hat somit offiziell die Häftlinge heraus genommen—ich weiß nicht, ob da internationale [unverständlich] gebrochen wurden oder was sie damals überhaupt dazu bewegt hat, dass sie die Häftlinge befreit haben. Und es hat damals ein bisschen Hoffnung in uns erweckt. Es waren...
David Boder: Aber sie kamen doch nicht heraus?
Helen Tichauer: Ich war geblieben. Es kam der erste Mai. Der erste Mai wurde in unseren Herzen als Tag der Freiheit gefeiert. Und am ersten Mai wurden wir auch aus dem Lager Meistro evakuiert. Und wir wussten...
David Boder: Warten Sie. Von wem wurden Sie evakuiert?
Helen Tichauer: Von der SS. Das war oben in Mecklenburg. Und wir ahnten und wir wussten, dieser Weg geht wirklich in die Freiheit und wir haben uns nicht getäuscht. Hinter der Stadt Goldberg...Wie viele Tage waren Sie unterwegs?
Helen Tichauer: Einen Tag und eine Nacht.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Helen Tichauer: Es war auf der Landstrasse Volk, Soldaten, Häftlinge, wie...was eben noch Hände und Füße hatte, ging in Richtung Lübeck. Ich persönlich mit zwei (2) Mädchen verschwand unter der Menge, wir haben uns los gerissen. Vorher hatten wir unsere Kleider vom roten Strich entfernt...
David Boder: Vom roten Streifen?
Helen Tichauer: Vom roten Streifen ja.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das getan?
Helen Tichauer: Ich selbst...als Malerin war immer darauf vorbereiten mir den Streifen nicht mit Ölfarbe sondern mit roter Wasserfarbe, die zwar nicht gedeckt hat, anzufertigen und mit leichtem Streichen mit einer Bürste konnte man den Streifen leicht entfernen. Und das hab ich unterwegs gemacht, hab mich...
David Boder: Und ihre Freundinnen?
Helen Tichauer: Ebenfalls. Wir haben uns unter [unverständlich] vermengt. Das war nicht schwer, denn es war ein zu großes Chaos, eine zu große Nervosität unter allen, selbstverständlich auch der SS. Und am Nachmittag fand ich ein abgelegenes, kleines Bauernhäuschen, ein kleines Gut, wo ich sah, dass die Deutschen ausziehen, das war deutsche Wehrmacht. Und kam daher auf die gute Idee in der Scheune schlafen zu gehen. In der Nacht...
David Boder: Mit wem waren Sie?
Helen Tichauer: Mit den zwei (2) Mädchen. Dort fanden wir aber auch schon Andere, die das selbe Ziel hatten, das heißt, die genau auf den gleichen Gedanken kamen. Das waren hauptsächlich französische Kriegsgefangene, etwas Russen, auch SS Angehörigen, die ihre Abzeichen weggeworfen haben und nicht mehr weiter tun wollten. Also ein Gemisch von einem Volk. Und die Nacht verbrachte man in der Scheune.
David Boder: Worüber haben Sie da gesprochen?
Helen Tichauer: Gesprochen? Es wurde darüber debattiert. Soll man weiter? Wir zogen weiter. Man kam mehr zu den Amerikanern. Warum sollen wir nicht von den Russen befreit werden? Und Häftlingen kann es doch egal sein, ob es ist von den Amerikanern oder von den Russen oder von den Engländern. Wir wollen nur befreit werden, wir wollen befreit sein. Und es ist schade unsere letzte Kraft noch her zu geben, denn wir waren ja ziemlich erschöpft und waren in einem Laufschritt quasi vorwärts zu kommen. Wir wussten, dass der Tag der Befreiung durch die Alliierten, egal welcher Nation, unser Tag ist, ja. Und...
David Boder: Und was haben die SS gesagt, die Deutschen?
Helen Tichauer: Sie haben...sie waren bereit hie zu bleiben und sich gefangen nehmen zu lassen. Da gab’s auch zwei Dänen oder Holländer— also jedenfalls von den Nord Staaten, zwei große Männer, die sich ziemlich unschlüssig waren und nicht wussten, was von ihnen gewollt war. Und sie wollten so ziemlich fort rennen. Und bei dem Zweifel habe ich ihnen eben gesagt, es lohnt sich nicht, denn eventuell würden sie unterwegs auch von den Deutschen erschossen werden. Sie sind geblieben. Und wirklich in der Nacht hörten wir im Wald—in der Nähe des Waldes—Kanonendonner. Das waren vielleicht auch [unverständlich; klingt wie Kakischka] wir waren ja doch...
David Boder: Was ist Kakischka?
Helen Tichauer: Kakischka ist eine russische Spezialwaffe. Wir waren Frauen und hatten keine besondere Kenntnis. Aber wir haben uns halt gedacht, in der Ober...an der Oberfront arbeiten die Russen hauptsächlich mit Kakischka und gegen drei (3) oder vier (4) Uhr kommt eine Stille. In der Früh waren wir hungrig. Auf dem Hof gab es Kartoffeln. Wir haben uns eben ein paar Kartoffeln gekocht, weil wir hungrig waren. Und plötzlich sahen wir einen Soldaten, also ein Uniformierter. Die Franzosen hatten ja ihre Uniform behalten. Uns haben die Uniformen nichts gemacht, denn wir waren ein Gemisch von allen. Und grüßte auf russisch ‚Zdravstvuy’. Darauf fragte ich ihn: ‚Wer bist Du?’. Er gibt mir keine Antwort. Ich erblicke...ich erblickte auf seiner Mütze den russischen Sowjet Stern. Und ich frage ihn irgendwie so in einem gebrochenen Russisch: ‚Bist Du ein russischer Soldat?’ Darauf sagt er ‚Ja.’ ‚Und sind die Russen schon da?’ Und er sagte: ‚Ja.’ ‚Und sind wir frei?’ Darauf sagte er: ‚Ja.’ Und es war ein russischer Sniper, so ein Vorbote und ich wusste das schon da, dass [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Nach einigen zehn Minuten kamen auf der Landstrasse verschiedene Panzerwagen, Pferde und Soldaten, Autos [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Da sie wussten, dass wir Häftlinge sind haben sie uns mit Lebensmittel und Konfitüren und dergleichen...
David Boder: Haben sie Lebensmittel gehabt?
Helen Tichauer: Ja, sie hatten Lebensmittel schon von...woher weiß ich nicht. Auf jedenfalls haben sie [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]...sie wissen, dass wir auf dem Weg sind. Auf der ganzen Linie gab es Häftlinge. Sie haben keine Rücksicht genommen, wenn sie in einem Dorf oder ein Stadt waren, dort alles zu requirieren und uns zu geben. Die Häftlinge waren halb nackt und halb verhungert und wir haben diese Dinge gebraucht. Diese Nacht, glaube ich, ja diese Nacht habe ich beschlossen heimwärts zu gehen und einen Tag...
David Boder: Nach Slowakien?
Helen Tichauer: Nach der Tschechoslowakei, richtig. Es war der dritte (3.) Mai. Und schon ein paar Stunden später haben sich [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband] die amerikanischen und russischen Truppen getroffen. Die selbe Nacht hielt ich ein Auto an, das bereits wieder von der Front zurück fuhr, um etwas zu holen. Es war ein russischer Kapitän. Ich ersuchte ihn uns mit zu nehmen.
David Boder: Alle drei?
Helen Tichauer: Alle drei. Er...
David Boder: Waren das jüdische Mädchen?
Helen Tichauer: Nein es waren auch zwei (2) polnische Mädchen dabei.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Er brachte uns bis zur Stadt Waren, wo er uns aussteigen ließ und uns noch Essen brachte und uns ein Zimmer zur Verfügung stellte.
David Boder: [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband].
Helen Tichauer: Nein, eine Wohnung. Und er hat gesagt, wir sollen uns da ein paar Stunden ausruhen und dass jedes Auto den Befehl hatte, Häftlinge eben aufzunehmen und dort hin zu transportieren unverständlich—sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband). Wir kamen dort an und waren in der Stadt Waren...
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Helen Tichauer: Eine deutsche Stadt in Mecklenburg. Dort trafen wir dann verschiedene Häftlinge aller Nationen. Zum ersten Mal sah ich...sah ich komische Uniformen, die mir, die mir noch unbekannt waren. Sie hatten Wagen und Pferde und Bündeln, wie alle anderen. Und ich fragte sie, wer sie sind. Darauf antworteten sie, sie wären amerikanische Kriegsgefangene, die jetzt auch schon befreit, mit Juden befreit wurden und dass ihr Ziel eben die amerikanische Zone wäre. Und da fragten sie dann, da fragten sie mich, was meine Nationalität wäre. Und ich habe ihnen gesagt, dass ich von Slowakien bin. Und da hatten sie Einen, Einen unter sich, dessen Eltern vor Jahren nach Amerika auswanderten, der auch aus der Tschechoslowakei stammt, sogar in der Nähe meine rHeimatstadt von Bratislava. Er wurde mir vorgestellt und er konnte noch irgendwie ein gebrochenes Tschechisch und wir haben uns unterhalten. Nach einer Weile verabschiedeten wir uns und haben uns bemüht wieder vorwärts zu kommen. Unterwegs trafen wir viele Menschen und alle waren nett und brachten uns [unverständlich]...wir haben uns verstanden...sie haben Verständnis für uns aufgebracht und haben uns geholfen unverständlich—sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband). Am acht und zwanzigsten (28) Mai sind wir schon angekommen—durch Polen nach Hause gekommen.
David Boder: Aber nicht mit der Bahn?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, nicht mit der Bahn...mit der Bahn erst aus Polen. Die ganze Zeit, wie es eben ging; mal zu Pferd, mal zu Fuß, mal mit Auto...mit einem Auto. Also für uns war es doch egal, nur vorwärts wollte man—nach Hause wollte man. Wir haben...[unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband] , aber natürlich der erste (1.) Weg [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Ich kam nach Hause und habe zufällig am ersten Tag gleich meinen einzigen Bruder, der noch über geblieben ist von Dreien, angefunden. Er selbst war zwei (2) Jahre lang vom Januar zwei und vierzig (42) im Gefängnis in Bratislava. Er wurde in ein jüdisches Sammellager geschickt, von dem er flüchtete und sich den Partisanen zur Verfügung stellte. Ein ein Halb (1 ½ ) Jahre verbrachte er in den Bergen. Er überlebte und wir trafen uns am sieben und zwanzigsten (27.) Mai, er war der Einzige, der zurückgekommen ist.
David Boder: Sind Sie in Ihre Wohnung zurück? Was haben sie dort vorgefunden?
Helen Tichauer: Die Wohnung ist längst arretiert worden, die Möbel, das heißt wir haben schon vor dem Krieg nicht viel...
David Boder: Was waren ihre Eltern vom Beruf?
Helen Tichauer: Mein Vater war Schneidermeister. Dinge, die ich zu Hause gelassen ha, na Kleider und solche Sachen, hat meine Mutter, es war meine zweite (2.) Mutter, zu meinem Meister, meinem Lehrmeister, meinem Arbeitgeber gebracht, das ist mein Chef für den ich zuletzt arbeitete...
David Boder: Und was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Helen Tichauer: Als Schriftmaler. Es ist kein [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband], er hat meine Dinge drei ein halb (3 ½ ) Jahre für mich aufbewahrt und sie mir dann ohne Aufforderung überbracht. Ich kam...
David Boder: Er war natürlich ein Christ? Ein...
Helen Tichauer: Ja, er ist ein Tscheche.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Ich kam ohne Schuhe nach Hause, ich kam ohne Kleider nach Hause. Das Einzige was ich aus Deutschland mitbrachte war eine Landkarte und [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband].
David Boder: Nun aus wie vielen Leuten bestand Ihre Familie?
Helen Tichauer: Meine Familie bestand aus Vater, Mutter und drei Brüdern. Einen Bruder fand ich.
David Boder: Und was sagte er von den Anderen?
Helen Tichauer: Er konnte nichts wissen, denn er war doch hinter Gittern, aber ich weiß durch Berichte von Anderen, dass meine Eltern...Augenzeugen, die meine Eltern abtransportieren gesehen haben im Juli zwei und vierzig (42) und die Transporte sind nicht mehr am Leben.
David Boder: Und die zwei (2 ) Brüder?
Helen Tichauer: Die zwei (2 ) Brüder sind mit gefahren, Einer war vierzehn (14), der andere Bruder...der eine Bruder ist...
David Boder: Den Sie gefunden haben?
Helen Tichauer: Der Älteste.
David Boder: Nun also...Sie waren...Sie hatten zwei Brüder?
Helen Tichauer: Drei.
David Boder: Drei Brüder. Und der dritte Bruder?
Helen Tichauer: Zwei Brüder sind mit den Eltern nach Lublin gegangen.
David Boder: Ja. Und der...der noch am Leben ist, ist der Dritte?
Helen Tichauer: Ja, das ist der Dritte und er ist zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Mit welchen Partisanen war er?
Helen Tichauer: Mit welchen, er war mit den slowakischen Partisanen, den slowakischen Truppe unter Mikolasch.
David Boder: Frau Tichauer, könnten Sie mir noch so ein bisschen Einzelheiten von dem Lagerleben erzählen, die sie wirklich selber gesehen haben oder near by beigewohnt haben?
Helen Tichauer: Also vom Lagerleben kann ich Ihnen sicher was erzählen, weil ich habe ja mitten drin gelebt. Aber über einzelne Eindrücke oder einzelne Gräueltaten sozusagen, die vielleicht [unverständlich] und denen ich beigewohnt habe, über diese [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband; Tonband fast unverständlich].
David Boder: Also gut...erzählen Sie mir, was Sie noch zu erzählen haben.
Helen Tichauer: Was ich, zum Beispiel, nicht vergessen kann, ist...das Feuer Tag und Nacht. Vier Kamine...
David Boder: Vier Schornsteine?
Helen Tichauer: Vier Schornsteine haben Tag und Nacht...
David Boder: Bitte lauter...weiter.
Helen Tichauer: . . . waren Tag und Nacht tätig. Und die Gruben wurden gemacht im Jahre vier und vierzig (44), wenn die ungarischen Transporte kamen, nicht wie andere Transporte [unverständlich], diese haben bei Nacht ein Bild ergeben, das man nicht beschreiben kann, weil man kam sich vor wie in einer lebenden Hölle. Man war rings herum von Feuer umgeben und unser Lager war...um unser Lager gab es nur einen Drahtzaun und dreißig Meter weiter war das Krematorium Nummer zwei (2). Also weit war es nicht und sehen konnte man, wenn man so wollte. Es gab Fälle, wo wir sehen konnten Menschen in Autos oder zu Fuß ins Krematorium rein spazieren und dann...einige Minuten später sah man nackte Leichen auf Tragbahren herausgeführt von den Bunkern. Und was konnte man sich dabei schon denken, man sah Feuer und Rauch. Man sah durch den Nebel kleine Gestalten...Kinder...das mussten Kinder gewesen sein...in den Gruben. Man sah bloß...man konnte...man kann sich vorstellen wie der Teufel...wie in der Hölle der Teufel seine Opfer [unverständlich] .
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir mal, Sie haben in der Schreibstube gearbeitet?
Helen Tichauer: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie was von den Zigeunern gehört?
Helen Tichauer: Natürlich.
David Boder: Also bitte erzählen Sie mir ausführlich alle Details...[beide sprechen]
Helen Tichauer: Also sehr ausführlich...
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Das Zigeuner Lager, das sogenannte Zigeuner Lager wurde im Jahre drei und vierzig (43) eingerichtet. Bekannt aus...von...von Quellen, von bestimmten Quellen her, warum eigentlich Zigeuner nach Auschwitz kamen, von bestimmten Quellen kann ich Folgendes sagen. Ungarn, das Land, das Juden bis zum Jahre vier und vierzig behielt, hatte kein Interesse vielleicht oder hat die Juden eben nicht ausgeliefert. Und Deutschland wusste nicht auf welche Art sie die ungarischen Juden bekommen. Im Jahre drei und vierzig (43), am Anfang drei und vierzig (43) sagte mir ein...eine Angestellte, die für den Lagerfuehrer arbeitet, dass sie hat ein Flüstern gehört. Das war Frau Wagner. Dass man die Zigeuner aus Ungarn bringen wird, nicht nur Zigeuner aus Ungarn—Zigeuner aus ganz Europa und, um da sie zu sammeln und dann nach Ungarn auszuliefern, weil ja angeblich Zigeuner in Ungarn in großen Zahlen vorhanden sind. Dafür uns aber Ungarn Juden ausliefern soll. Es war damals, hm, ziemlich unklar, weil keiner wusste davon. Ich selbst hatte die Möglichkeit...nicht nur ich, sondern es gab Monate wo man offiziell nach Hause schreiben durfte. Ich habe an meine Freundin, die Verwandte in Ungarn hatte, eine Karte gerichtet. Durch die Blume—sie haben es verstanden, dass ungarische Juden zu erwarten sind. Anfang drei und vierzig (43) , da ist in der Mitte von drei und vierzig (43) habe ich ihr geschrieben, nicht offiziell, aber durch die Blume natürlich.
David Boder: Was heißt „durch die Blume“?
Helen Tichauer: Ich hab, zum Beispiel...ein Beispiel...ich muss wirklich kein Beispiel erwähnen, denn ich habe die Karte, die ich geschickt habe zu Hause bei meinem Bruder da. Ich habe, zum Beispiel, Folgendes geschrieben: Der Name der Freundin war Grete. Zu Hause wurde Sie Gitti genannt. Ja, ich bin Ilonka in ungarisch. Also ich habe geschrieben: „Gitti, ich bin Ilonka’s Freundin.“ Gitti hatte Verwandte in Schuran. Schuran ist eine ungarische Stadt. „Ich habe gehört, dass Sie die Absicht haben zu Ilonka zu ziehen. Ich würde Ihnen davon abraten, indem Sie da keine Lebensmöglichkeit.“ Ich konnte da nichts Anders schreiben.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Aber sie wusste genau, ich bin Ilonka, sie ist Gitti und Shuranier sind Ungarn., ungarische Juden. Kein Mensch, kein Teufel konnte sich damals vorstellen, dass man wirklich die Absicht hatte, ungarische Juden zu bringen. Und das Schicksal kam so. Ungarische Juden kamen ohne Zigeuner. Hitler hat dann Ungarn besetzt und hat die Juden mit Gewalt genommen , also gewaltsam genommen. Und Zigeuner, deutsche Zigeuner, Mischlinge, Zigeuner aus Polen, aus der Tschechoslowakei und aus allen anderen Ländern...ich will nicht...ich spreche jetzt nicht von den Wanderzigeunern, nur von den anständigen Zigeunern, von geschulten Leuten, von den Mischlingen.
David Boder: Geschult? Wofür?
Helen Tichauer: Bürokräfte und noch geben könnten, wurden wo, geschulte Musikern, ganz intelligente Elemente, also wirklich sehr wertvolle Menschen, die wirklich der Menschheit viel geboten haben und noch bieten können, wurden irgendwo in ein Zigeunerlager samt Familie untergebracht.
David Boder: Sie wohnten Frauen, Männer und Kinder zusammen?
Helen Tichauer: Richtig. Und das Zigeuner Lager das war der Abschnitt B 2 E. Der Abschnitt war so, zuerst war das kleine Frauenlager. Das war...das lag...waagrecht und an der Strasse der Länge nach lagen Abschnitt A, das war das Quarantänelager der Männer, Abschnitt 2 das gehörte dem Tschechen Lager, darüber dürfte man auch so Manches noch sagen. Der Abschnitt C lag an der Lager Strasse—eine Strasse, Abschnitt D war das Männerlager Birkenau, Abschnitt E das Zigeunerlager, Abschnitt F das Männer Krankenbau, Abschnitt B 2 G...
David Boder: Hm.
Helen Tichauer: . . . war Brzezinki Birkenau—das Lager am Krematorium. Die Zigeuner haben die ganzen Juden Transporte in Krematorium mit angesehen. Sie haben das Verbrennen mit angesehen. Sie waren ungefähr 200 Meter entfernt. Und als man sie aufforderte die Autos zu besteigen...
David Boder: Wieso? Hat man beschlossen die Zigeuner zu vernichten?
Helen Tichauer: Berlin hat beschlossen die Zigeuner zu vernichten—alle. Die jungen Zigeuner wurden gesammelt, sie wurden in die Wagons aufgeladen vor dem Zigeuner Lager; die Schienen wurden bis zum Krematorium gelegt. Und die Leute, die Zigeuner sahen, dass ihre Angehörigen in die entgegengesetzte Richtung fahren. Und richtig, diese Zigeunerinnen habe ich nämlich im Jahre fünf und vierzig (45) in Ravensbrück getroffen. Aber was mit den Anderen geschah, wusste keiner, denn die Jungen wurden abtransportiert, auch junge Männer, aber das war nur ein Bruchteil von denen, ein kleiner Bruchteil und junge Frauen. Und der Rest wurde aufgefordert Autos zu besteigen. Sie haben sich geweigert und haben geantwortet: „Wir wollen nicht mit den Juden verbrannt werden.“ Man gab ihnen dann zwei (2), drei (3) Wochen Ruhe. Und dann hat man es eben getan, indem man die Jungen evakuiert. An demselben Tag, wo man die jungen Zigeuner in Wagons aufgeladen hat und nach Richtung Bahnhof Auschwitz, also in die andere Richtung als zum Krematorium abgeführt hat, haben die alten Zigeuner wieder etwas Hoffnung bekommen und sagten, dass sie jetzt auch abtransportiert werden...aber dieser Transport ging ins Krematorium. Und was sich in dieser Nacht abgespielt hat, darüber was die Häftlinge erzählt haben, die im Lager 2B—im Lager Brzezinki—gearbeitet haben. Es gab furchtbare Szenen. Das Lager, das Zigeuner Lager, war einen Tag später leer und die nächsten ungarischen Juden Transporte, die dann kamen von Männern, wurden in diesem Lager untergebracht.
David Boder: Nun ist es wahr, dass die Zigeuner nicht einmal vergast wurden?
Helen Tichauer: Doch, warum denn nicht? Die Deutschen hat kein Interesse sich die Arbeit zu erschweren. Ganz im Gegenteil—das Vergasen ging sehr höflich vor sich. Die SS war verhältnismäßig höflich und ruhig, denn sie wollten nicht, dass ein Durcheinander geschieht. Sie wollten, dass die Leute sie haben den Leuten Ruhe geboten, denn sie selbst wollten in ihrer Arbeit nicht gestört werden. Mit einer ganz heimtückischen Art haben sie die Leute herein gelockt. Und da wir gerade über das Zigeuner Lager reden, nicht weit vom Zigeuner Lager war auch das Tschechen Lager, das Lager bestand aus tschechischen Juden, die automatisch mit ihren Familien aus Theresienstadt kamen.
David Boder: Warum?
Helen Tichauer: Theresienstadt.
David Boder: Ich weiß Bescheid über Theresienstadt.
Helen Tichauer: Theresienstadt hatte Transporte nach Auschwitz gehabt. Damals...es wurde gesagt, dass Leuten in Auschwitz nichts passiert. Sie wurden mit ihren Familien beisammen gehalten. Sie konnten Briefe schreiben, sie konnten Päckchen erhalten...und was geschah nach sechs (6) Monaten? Genau nach sechs (6) Monaten—war es mit den ersten (1.), zweiten (2.) und dritten (3.) Transporten—wenn sechs (6) Monate um waren, hat man...Zum Beispiel, wenn ein Transport...am neunzehnten (19.) Februar wurde das ganze Tschechen Lager—ausnahmslos jung und alt, gesund und krank...vergast. Einen Tag vorher...
David Boder: Februar vier und vierzig (44)?
Helen Tichauer: Vier und vierzig (44). Zum Beispiel, einen Tag vorher mussten die nach Theresienstadt, vor allem nach Böhmen und Mähren, schreiben mit dem Datum einen Monat voraus. Und dann, wenn London das Vergasen in Theresienstadt...des Tschechen Lagers in Birkenau angesagt hat, konnte es...
David Boder: Was haben sie...
Helen Tichauer: London hat angesagt. Und die Deutschen haben dementiert: „Wieso denn? Die Post kommt einen Monat später noch aus Birkenau an ihre Bekannten...an ihre Verwandten, von denen, die sie für tot halten.
David Boder: Sie haben es später datieren müssen?
Helen Tichauer: Mussten. Richtig. Einen Monat später.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Wenn sie im Februar vergast wurden, mussten sie März schreiben.
Helen Tichauer: Und dadurch wurden die nächsten Theresienstädter Juden irritiert. Es kamen weitere Transporte, sie wurden wieder sechs (6) Monate mit ihren Familien beisammen gelassen und dann wurden wieder vergast. Und die...die letzten Transporte kamen aus Theresienstadt, teilweise junge Mädchen—schon sortiert in Theresienstadt. Von denen leben heute welche und der allerletzte Transport wurde ganz normal behandelt, wie alle Anderen. Von diesen Transporten wurden neunzig (90) Prozent der Leute in die Gaskammer geschickt und zehn (10) Prozent ins Lager hinein.
David Boder: Hm.
Helen Tichauer: So endete Theresienstadt. Ich persönlich in, hm,...mit Zusammenarbeit mit einem Herrn Schön, der schon jahrelang im Konzentrationslager sich befand, ein tschechischer Häftling, im Zusammenhang mit einer Tschechin Lotte Batja, eine tschechische Jüdin, wir haben Pläne vom Krematorium raus geschmuggelt nach Theresienstadt, damit die Leute, die danach kommen, wissen wohin...wohin der Weg führt.
David Boder: Also Sie sagen, Sie haben zu den Transporten, hm, Nachrichten geschickt?
Helen Tichauer: Nachrichten geschickt, die angekommen sind. Nur leider hat die Führung in Theresienstadt sich leider sehr, sehr schwer [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband] lassen.
David Boder: Die jüdische Führung?
Helen Tichauer: Auch. Sie haben selbst Angst gehabt. Ich hab nachträglich einen Herren getroffen, der aus Theresienstadt kam und der viel gekannt hat von Theresienstadt. Das war ein Dr. Vollmeier, der nur was flüstern gehört hat, aber nichts Konkretes erfahren konnte. [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Um zu beweisen, dass diese Transporte tatsächlich ins Gas gingen, kann ich nur verweisen auf...auf die Diagramme, die ich selbst fertigen musste, ja. Von einem Tag zum anderen Tausende von Menschen sind gefallen, [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband].
David Boder: [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]
Helen Tichauer: [unverständlich; sehr starkes Rauschen im Tonband]...ausserdem die Tatsache ich war der einzige Häftling, der nicht in den Transport ging, dass ich die Zeichnerin von Dr.Mengele oder es waren Zwillinge, die befreit wurden. Der Dr. Mengele hat studiert an verschiedenen Zwillingspaaren, und so weiter. Und jetzt im Zusammenhang damit was man da vorgetäuscht hat mit Arbeitstransporten und Transporten zu Gas...übrigens möchte ich eine kleine Kleinigkeit bloß erwähnen. Eines Abends würde in unseren Abschnitten...in unserem Abschnittslager zwei tausend (2000) Frauen herüber gebracht. Alle zwei Tausend (2000) gebadet, eingekleidet und auf Transport...auf den Transport vorbereitet. Wir in der Schreibstube wussten, dass nur tausend (1000) Frauen Auftrag haben in ein Arbeitslager zu gehen, denn wir haben bei unserem Appell die Stärke abgeschrieben bis das Lager gemeldet hat, der Transport ist da. Die anderen zwei Tausend (2000) wurden als SB Behandlung verzeichnet.
David Boder: Sonder-Behandlung?
Helen Tichauer: Sonder-Behandlung. Und wie nun eigentlich das Transportieren und die Täuschung vor den Anderen vor sich ging, weiß ich jetzt: Es standen vor dem Lager Wagons und es standen hinter den Wagons Lastautos. Es gingen erst hundert (100) Mädchen raus—es war abends—wurden in die Wagons gejagt. Die nächsten Hundert (100) auf Autos, die dritten Hundert (100) in die Wagons, die Nächsten vier Hundert auf Autos.
David Boder: Wo stand das Auto?
Helen Tichauer: Hinter den Wagons—parallel.
David Boder: So dass...
Helen Tichauer: So dass die Häftlinge, die in die Wagons gingen, nicht gewusst haben wohin die Autos gehen und die in den Autos wussten nicht wohin die Wagons fahren und...
David Boder: Aber die brauchten nicht durch die Wagons zu gehen zu den Autos?
Helen Tichauer: Nein. Es wurden zwei auseinander genommen und es war ein Weg frei. Und dann ging’s los. Die Wagons gingen wirklich auf Transport in ein anderes Lager und die anderen Tausend wurden vergast. Erst kamen dieselben Kleider wider zurück und zweitens mussten wir eben vermerken: Sonder Behandlung. So dass man nie wusste, woran man ist. Nie.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie einmal, was für ein—sozusagen—Heim oder Lager gibt es hier? Geben Sie mir eine kurze Beschreibung. Und was planen die Leute hier zu tun, um sich zu beschäftigen?
Helen Tichauer: Das Camp Feldafing ist ein Lager, welches gleich nach der Befreiung von Herrn Leutnant Smith...
David Boder: Also ist das die UNRRA?
Helen Tichauer: Nein, damals noch von Leutnant Smith von der Armee geplant, die das Lager erobert hat, das heißt, die Gegend erobert hat. Dieses Lager wurde von Leutnant Smith unter Beschlag genommen, denn er war Zeuge, dass hier Tausend von Häftlingen in den Wagons halb verhungert standen ohne zu wissen wohin. Das ist hier ein Gebiet von der Reichsschule der Hitler Jugend. Das Lager wurde hier in Beschlag genommen und die Leute von ihren Kleidern befreit, in requirierten...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Helen Tichauer: . . . von ihren Kleidern befreit. Das heißt abgenommen und in Pyjamas gesteckt. Der Leutnant Smith...
David Boder: Von wo hatten sie die Pyjamas?
Helen Tichauer: Die Pyjamas, die...haben sie hier im Lager gefunden.
David Boder: Oh von der Hitler Jugend?
Helen Tichauer: Richtig. Leutnant Smith hat damals gleich einen Block geschaffen für Unterernährte, das heißt, fast jeder hier war unterernährt.
David Boder: Sie waren natürlich nicht hier?
Helen Tichauer: Ich war nicht hier, denn ich...als ich nach Hause kam, war mein erster Weg hierher zu kommen und den Rest meiner Familie zu suchen. Und ich hab hier keinen gefunden, außer meinem Mann, den ich hier kennenlernte.
David Boder: Nun also, was hat Smith getan?
Helen Tichauer: Smith hat den Leuten ganz sukzessive mit der Nahrung begonnen. Das heißt, er hat mit der Nahrung sukzessive mit dem Grießbrei begonnen und hat mit den kompaktesten Dingen geendet. Die Verpflegung stand unter Kontrolle, die Menschen waren verhungert, waren unterernährt und es war schwer die Leute wieder auf die Beine zu stellen.
David Boder: Also da kamen Sie von Süden und von anderen Regionen?
Helen Tichauer: Wir versammelten uns hier und wurden untergebracht.
David Boder: Wer war eigentlich Leutnant Smith?
Helen Tichauer: Er war in der Army.
David Boder: Aber...aber er...
Helen Tichauer: Ein Jude.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Ein amerikanischer Jude.
David Boder: Wissen Sie seinen ersten Namen, seinen Vornamen?
Helen Tichauer: Ja. Erwin...Irving.
David Boder: Irving?
Helen Tichauer: Irving Smith.
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Als die Armee...Und das Lager Feldafing war zur damaligen Zeit das einzige Lager, wo es die wenigsten Todesfälle gab. Er hat Tag und Nacht zusammen...in Zusammenarbeit mit meinem heutigen Manne und viele Andere noch, zum Wohle der Menschen hier gearbeitet. Die Leute wurden—haben sich nach Wochen erholt und wie gesagt, der kleinste Prozentsatz von allen anderen Camps zusammen, die damals eingerichtet wurden, und Todesfälle hatte Feldafing damals die Wenigsten. Inzwischen ist ein Jahr vergangen, nachher übernahm die UNRRA das Lager.
David Boder: Also wie wurde das Lager erhalten bis die UNRRA es übernahm?
Helen Tichauer: Durch die Armee.
David Boder: Durch die Armee und dann hat es die UNRRA übernommen?
Helen Tichauer: Ja, die UNRRA übernommen und die Leute sind hier seit einigen Jahren, trotz Verpflegung, trotz Quartierung sind alle schon sehr ungeduldig, und jeder hat ein einziges Ziel vor sich, das Land zu verlassen, welches ehemals zur Hölle war.
David Boder: Und wohin wollen sie gehen?
Helen Tichauer: Gehen? Sie haben ein Ziel, raus aus Europa, zum Teil...
David Boder: Wollen viele nach Palästina gehen?
Helen Tichauer: Natürlich, es gibt Leute, jung—hauptsächlich die Jugend, die umsichtig sind, die lernen wollen, die einen nationalen Judenstaat haben wollen—sich zu Hause fühlen. Hauptsächlich Jugend.
David Boder: Hm.
Helen Tichauer: Es gibt dann wieder einen Teil von Juden, die eine Verwandte in Amerika haben und ihre ganze europäische Familie verloren haben und jetzt den Rest dieser Familie aufsammeln und mit ihnen ein Leben verbringen wollen. Daneben auch mit der Absicht einen Beruf zu erlernen, sich angleichen als frei, als freie Arbeiter...als freie Arbeiter in einem amerikanischen Staat eben zu leben.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, haben Sie irgend welchen Kontakt mit den Deutschen hier herum?
Helen Tichauer: Kontakt mit den Deutschen? Nein. Eigentlich nicht, denn die Deutschen in Ober Bayern haben ja auch gar nicht das Bedürfnis, den Kontakt mit uns aufzunehmen. Sie haben auch gar nicht...die Absicht irgendwie sich...schuldig zu fühlen, obwohl wir genau wissen, dass Ober Bayern sehr wenig Menschen hat, sehr wenig Angehörige haben, die in der Partei waren oder war das Zentrum der Parteitagung. Wir haben Nürnberg, wir haben München.
David Boder: Sie waren alle in der Partei?
Helen Tichauer: Zum Grossteil und ich kann Eines sagen; die deutsche Bevölkerung in anderen Ländern Deutschlands ist ganz anders.
David Boder: Besser?
Helen Tichauer: Besser als die Ober Bayern. Und eben darum kann man auch nicht von unseren Leuten verlangen, dass wir irgendwelche Sympathie...
David Boder: Was ist...?
Helen Tichauer: . . . oder irgendwelchen Kontakt mit den Leuten aufnehmen sollen. Wir verstehen, es gibt Kinder, vielleicht unschuldige deutsche Kinder, die genau so unschuldig sind, wie es unsere Kinder waren, die auch in Scharen niedergeschossen wurden. Und deswegen haben wir ein Lied komponiert. Der Hass [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband], aber wir kennen überhaupt keinen Hass, aber wir fühlen alle, wir sind heute noch gehasst. Noch gehasst!
David Boder: Nun...und Sie selbst, wo wollen Sie hin gehen?
Helen Tichauer: Ich selbst...
David Boder: Mit ihrem Mann?
Helen Tichauer: Ich selbst—nicht mit meinem Mann, der eigentlich aus Berlin stammt und ein deutscher Jude ist, sich aber als staatenlos bekennt. Ich schätze, wenn ich diesen Mann nicht gefunden hätte, ich möchte in der Tschechoslowakei leben, würde gerne dort leben, weil ich hab mich da immer gut gefühlt—ich kenne die Mentalität—ich fühle mich mit der Tschechoslowakei verbunden.
David Boder: Und sonst wollen Sie nach Süd Amerika gehen?
Helen Tichauer: Und sonst, hm...und sonst...
David Boder: Ja.
Helen Tichauer: Mein Mann hat noch den Rest seiner Familie in Süd Amerika. In Deutschland wird er sich nie mehr wohl fühlen. In diesem Land gibt es nichts für uns.
David Boder: [In English] We regret we have to finish this interview. The automobile is waiting. This concludes Spool 150.